[Music]
thank you
yes sir
know might check my check
roll call in the round roll calling
around how we doing how we feeling out
here
I'm late
I'm running late you know what I mean
let's talk to the people right quick
talk to what's going on General Mac
follow us with a chat you said it's all
hail the IOP salute the Lord shout out
to the chat great to see everyone have a
great show let's get it no doubt OG from
the Bay Area salute Lydia Master what's
going on good morning I don't feed No
Doubt popped out what's up Lord Metro
hey you turn on the building
Skywalker UAV no doubt salute salute
live Supremacy what's going on what's
going on talk to me let me know how the
levels are sounding we got the Donald
talking with the five dollar Super Chat
I don't remember y'all dedicated an
entire topic to Pokemon 12 million in
three days being the fastest exclusive
ever media bias oh okay okay calling the
Lords out on the Nintendo success no
doubt no doubt fair enough we need to do
better about that we we require certain
performance threshold
your Fray rate gotta be good before we
can acknowledge it
we gotta be able to walk
straight and blade what's up what's
going on how about levels AKA this is my
level is good oh hustling motivated
salute thank you thank you no doubt no
doubt I see what it is so yeah we're
gonna be running a little late we're a
little hot you know what I'm saying
addict talk to the people right quick
[Music]
we all want that
look down no doubt
but um what we gonna do we're gonna do a
quick mic check it's all pulling up
really soon came very soon so we're
gonna have to mute this yeah we got mute
now so we see y'all in a bit
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
using these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
the song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rains you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got you
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
am look y'all messed up and turned me to
an animal and headless be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
it regardless back weed with messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social or my city
but I'm still bicosal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all to Dramatical I know it's
random but I'm addicted to flipping and
sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
hell ow look y'all messed up and turned
me to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers they don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got you man
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
am look y'all messed up and turned me to
an animal and headless be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all to
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and Sample and
making it flammable this is that this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
you just a Target when I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but that's all a part of me being a
cannibal and they say I'm better than
money because you can Bank on me being
accountable I know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable I kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to Freddie and
Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original you're also Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
[Music]
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee Bender I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnido who cares if he flies you
stealing mosquito you swear he ain't
something but really be Stevo you like
to collect stuff and that's cool but I
got bad news even if he really was that
joke he ain't never still be the king of
the statue sister juvenile I've been
cursed with a curse to be Musical and if
you hate it we'll meet in The Crucible
other than nothing it's cool and it's
beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday it's suitable cause you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday a suitable
cause you can listen to this in your
cubicle on the Lord day
[Music]
yes yes yes yes yes yes by checking all
of that can I do some checking yeah yeah
yeah
the Lords what's going on and here are
you here hello
you might as well put the voice
modulator back
I missed the voice modulee yeah did you
take it off did you take it off no it's
not that I took it off I'm gonna do
research and how to make like certain
voices okay I don't like just like okay
I'm just gonna race the pitch
he's like would you get that thing from
him yeah
they thought it was funny too
saying that it wasn't funny
but you know they need to realize real
quick I don't care what they think yes
and we are live and welcome to the iron
Lords podcast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode 290 10 away
from a certain number another glorious
Sunday and we're back at the round table
why are you highlighting 300. I'm just
saying that it's a nice round a rice
round number I like that no it's like
you're trying to foreshadow something
I'm just saying you know there's a movie
called 300 it's a lot of symbolism that
doesn't end well though let's not oh
yeah
let's not use that one
listen we all got to go but I want to go
memorable exactly that is true remember
my name that's true I mean uh so I want
to go like Thanos in the other Galaxy uh
planting
fruits
that's the way you get that gangster
list Sunday from that's ridiculous you
want to go out
I could see I could see Kings he's like
a little thing where he's like I took my
helmet off so I could see that bad boy
so he can see my eyes
every time we play fortnite We Tell Adam
Yo hold on let's calm down and get this
victory
yeah he he don't run out in heaven says
that'll run out into the business yeah
these four Dudes down there I must show
myself yeah yeah he's definitely yeah
most of the time it ends bad for him
at least he admit it thank you and it's
a glorious Sunday we're back at the
round table the Lord's date and today
we've got Titan full game cancellation
gear six and the Coalition
God of War Ragnarok and PS5 sales
PlayStation Plus collection
it's like he's reading a menu
[Laughter]
did the pre-orders to discuss so we
gonna get right into it so let's
introduce the four Horsepen of gaming
those original gaming nights in the room
here at the round table my co-host with
the combos my brother from another
mother the difficult game conqueror Lord
of his own world and the how of the
young wolf my man Lord addict of the
attic show how we doing sir doing pretty
good uh you know first thing I want to
say is a shout out to PlayStation for
finally uh kind of Keeping Up With The
Times They have that beta going for
Discord uh you know I think that's or
I've always thought it's weird to have
cross play with not like a a third-party
place for everyone to go to
to go to the talk yeah but now PC people
can jump on Discord because they've
always had access to it Xbox people
could jump on Discord hopefully in a
couple months uh p uh Playstation uh
fans could jump on Discord and it's like
you know I think that's that's the way
well they're in beta right now so I
don't know if it's gonna take a couple
of months
I don't know
why we got creative boys but this could
yo but how long has Discord been out
with they not in this I just need to
know because I got a lot of friends that
play on PlayStations
I think you know one of the the goals I
had this year is to restructure our
Discord because if they if Discord is
that accessible
okay
thank you yeah so here we go
it's been pretty good you know um if I I
beat Fire Emblem finally
yeah something how was that right yeah
it's good you know I have hold up
I have the review coming out at the end
of the show so you guys can uh check in
on that uh for those of you who saw my
high five rush and I went in there and
supported it I appreciate it yes I
really enjoyed that game regardless what
the the internet wants you to think
that's a good game
what's the internet anything they can to
distract the front from the Xbox has a
banger today
you mean it's the beta boys
yeah I mean look you say tomato I say
tomorrow
so all right so the gummies is out here
talking about
so the Gunnies is out here they met at
high five rush because all Xbox dudes is
in love with high five right so
obviously by by a masterful deduction
it has to be the beta boys the gunny
dude
I'm just trying to figure it out because
I was you know I was on Xbox I saw
people posting on Twitter and tagging
Phil saying bring it to Playstation Xbox
people don't deserve a game
definitely needs it charging really wow
hey 85.50
this game ain't that long and that dual
[__] still ain't gonna last the whole
game
I I was playing yesterday on my
PlayStation I had to swap out my dual
sense four times bro wait what happened
I'll tell you what my turn
I had to swap it out four times yeah and
then one thing I want to say is you know
I I all jokes aside I really love the
fact that we have you know the Discord
thing going on because now you know I
could jump in play with the the
PlayStation weirdos when I want to oh
man what's going on
look man
the way what is going on
they know they know I'm joking
they don't take the sarcasm well exactly
that's Invader for them
I just I really enjoy the fact that you
know especially when you have like a lot
of cross play games yes which I I want
to point out that like these developers
like now that we have Discord coming to
everything it's like man you have no
reason not to have cross play like it
helps your game it doesn't do anything
but help the the game it's like just do
it like I think so yeah besides PC we
don't want to play PC people because I
love you bro
all right let me get this right because
I'm failing back today I just took my
focus so I'm trying to you know you got
yourself just take my focus so I'm I'm
drinking my focus right here so so you
know and it helps you focus because this
is what I'm trying to do so little by
little my focus is you know kicking in
y'all get that information
it's not open okay you've got that
premium energy son so that's that's for
about an hour and okay so that's when
you okay so you're trying to double up
then yeah I just took my gummy so I'm
pretty good I'm pretty good
um my question is okay so now my focus
is kicking and I'm getting it right now
I'm saying it you want to have uh cross
play only between Xbox and PlayStation
and maybe some Nintendo's but you want
to exclude the PC race I want cross play
PVP wise to be to be where you could
turn it off from PC yes
here's the thing I want to exclude the
group when there's a bunch of cheaters
in the group now it's okay if you cheat
when you're on my team
if you're going against me isn't it like
a blanket statement
that not all PC dudes cheat yeah but
enough of them will definitely you know
not all people cheat but enough of them
going to ruin your experience regardless
that is that is so messed up like that's
like all men cheat
codes
especially me and call I had a little
bit more experience because I played a
little bit more on the PC but there was
an absurd amount of cheating on Destiny
on PC it was wild there were times I was
playing Fall Guys you can ask Cat Daddy
Cat Daddy deleted fall guys because of
this where we were doing the little one
where uh the platforms keep going down
they're floating in the air just doing
like Earth was floating in the air it's
just like nah like look
do the majority of PC cheaters cheat of
course not but that five percent is a
lot of people wait wait he said do the
majority of PC cheaters cheats
but here's the thing it isn't just me
they shut off cities from Cross play for
PC because of cheating like it is a
serious issue the reason why Microsoft
don't want you getting the booty on the
cheap
they want you to earn the booty they
don't want you to just go in there and
get the booty on the cheek Microsoft
made sure that you know you can't be
cheating to get the movie
I ain't get to it because they're
cheating I'm gonna be stuck in the
traffic that's what it feels like I'm on
PC cheating
you know I just focused in on it yeah
your focus kicking it your IPS is high
okay continue
yeah so I mean you know that that's
pretty much right for playing uh next
week I will be start uh I'm gonna start
live streaming more
um you know
uh twitch I'm still debating I'm I'm
halfway between twitch and YouTube
actually I might put in the chat what
would people watch YouTube or twitch
I'm going to uh I'm gonna be streaming
the Harry Potter game oh so that's
that's going to be interesting I'm gonna
be I'm gonna just be real with you guys
I'm Gonna Be a Menace in that game
oh and I don't know who I'm going it
doesn't matter people getting killed
what I'm doing
so it's like it's like
um watching about Elden ring
no it's worse than apparently you like
you could kill like you could you could
commit massacres and stuff in that game
like it's it's definitely one of those
morale games see I see look I was not
thinking about this game but if I can do
like Elden ring and I can invade other
people's stuff no it's not like that
there's no there's no multiplayer form
of thing in there but like apparently
you could just
start just casting spells on your
classmates
I'm gonna be the next Voldemort okay
like you you know what you know how
people say for the person whose name
cannot be imma be so bad they're gonna
just Erase Me from history so it's like
Fable oh okay yeah I guess I don't know
I haven't played it yet but yeah
something pretty much it sir
yeah so what's the attic of the uh gonna
be marking all the NPCs
I'm gonna be so bad in that game it's
just gonna be me everyone else is dead
all right there you go there's there's
the Hogwarts experience
and of course we have our most tactical
gaming load the solo game who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the soft stradamus the Lord of
clarity and Lord patreon of the iron
bank my man Lord Sovereign how are we
doing sir
he's muted he's so he's so lit he's
Beauty Mad Libs there you go he's bad
for a minute I'm over here
that you talking about what's up I'm
good I'm chilling yeah
not much gaming to do during the week
I'm consistent lately yeah yes yes and
once again I actually played maybe 15
minutes of Hi-Fi Rush okay uh it looks
seems super fun man everything about
that game like when you really look at
that animation you're like oh wow like
it's crazy yeah yeah it's crazy have yet
to boot up dead space have not done that
yet um
because I'll let you guys know I was I'm
expecting my new laptop this week so I'm
excited to throw everything on there the
inspection
yeah I gotta I got a couple of sneers a
couple of weeks ago when I said I was
getting a laptop I will remind you
ladies and gentlemen that if I were to
get a banging 40 90 desktop for my house
it would be collecting dust with my
consoles over there
so it'll make no sense so you know I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go with a 40 90
laptop and get all the fraps I can with
the laptop but
um what I did yesterday though right
yesterday I woke up by the way it was
freezing
bro bro it's crazy yeah yo that
windshield you know what to do we're not
gonna come out the house
bro it's really unwise it was so mad my
boy saw me I hopped out the car right
yeah man it's brick outside I said my
car is 90 degrees
[Laughter]
so yeah I was like you know what I got
up had some some errands and stuff to do
but it was just cold uh you know what
doing nothing I thought we had a meeting
yesterday didn't happen because me and
you was the only dude yeah
I was in the mountains so I'm looking at
the text meeting at 12.
that was like 1101 yeah
all the way up from beer Mountain
because I got to get more beer fur
I mean I'm shooting down the mountain
you see me flying I'm doing 90 down the
mountain I'm like oh I gotta get back
home I could have been horrible if he
got pulled over and got to take it first
yeah
I went and got pulled over because I was
looking like a whole bed driving the car
so the car would have been like I was
like why is an animal driving this car
no he's definitely not gonna pull him
over there he said no he's late for the
circus
I get to the house I run inside I'm like
it was the link where's the link it's
just me and solve on the phone talk
me and saw had like a 25 minute
conversation about the about the meeting
that was happening yeah
we don't have to have a meeting
oh God anyway continue so that so I was
like you know what an attic was supposed
to send me something to work on and that
didn't happen either so I was like you
know what I ain't doing nothing today I
just plop myself in front of the TV
common did the TV because wife would be
funny she was trying to grab up the TV
I'm like babe you know you have you you
literally have the TV six out of seven
I'm never here and Sundays belong to you
anyway because I'm podcasting yeah so
leave me the TV
and so I'm there and I'm I'm throwing on
Ragnarok cause I have not played rock
and rock in a minute I spent the whole
day playing Ragnarok which is why I had
to swap out my my controller like four
times but it's just it dies super quick
man I have two controllers swapping back
and forth dropping back and forth but
it's apparently without a lead
controllers this is the Dual sense
control there we go
apparently that new one is way worse is
worse yeah it's going to be dope if um
you had the ability to just you know put
in double a batteries or wouldn't be
dope if the elite controller doesn't
have double a batteries
no the elite controller too is
chargeable it doesn't do batteries right
anybody ask for your input
it's too fast
so I spent literally the whole day
playing Ragnarok and that that's not
saying much because oftentimes you don't
when you I looked I was like I didn't
really do that much but I was playing
the whole day yeah there's a lot of side
quests once you're cool I like the side
quests there they're like they have some
relevance to the story is always
something that it's just not BS you know
like like some games I like that
um I'm enjoying it more and more I think
the the big thing is the acting the
acting is really like the conversations
that go down
um the comment even I I can understand
um
I got to see more of Odin okay okay
he is
yes he does he has this thing where he's
just very like like sarcastic about
everything and he's very like he does
not appear Odin like except in in the
way in the way that he manipulates he's
everything he does is like he's doing
something I'm not quite sure what it is
but it's sheisty and I like that aspect
of him I like no okay I'm enjoying him
more you all right see I grew up on my
own being a man in his word you know my
old and being above all my old and being
omnipotent right
[Music]
yeah I told you I put it hashtag not my
owner but but um my Odin don't need to
lie don't need to cheat don't need to
steal my Odin already I'm above all like
I'm the god like I'm here so I don't
care what you're saying like when he
smack Thor down and you like I take your
powers away go learn your life again
again it's so powerful this Odin reminds
me of Loki grew up Odin and he walk in
the room like an old pimp loading Odin
and he's like but he's still he still
exercises that power it's what you
notice he exercises that power it's just
that the power he exits he's created a
totally totally disjointed Family Circle
like it is messed up it is completely
and it's his fault right right and he
acknowledges that like he if you notice
how he talks to Thor yeah and like he's
like and and and there's a moment where
character has like yo why do you act
like that he's like that's the only
language he understands like straight up
and it's so he's still the all father
it's just that the situation he's
created is so toxic it's like so it's
it's a take on that character the same
way when you meet when you meet Heimdall
he's different than what the two
characters yeah yes uh so but I'm
enjoying it because immediately when you
see these characters
you get a sense of place and what this
place is to live in and what it is to be
around these people so they do a really
good job of that and I I can kind of
start seeing the Christopher Judge you
know acting stuff like because Kratos
he's like always grunting screaming
whatever but in this game there's he has
kind of more to chew on where there's
things that he has to address that he
necessarily doesn't want to address
right and it's necessary for him to sort
of expound more and have deeper
conversations and I'm I'm seeing more of
that so that's I'm really enjoying that
the gameplay is there nothing is really
you know I it was funny though I was
doing a puzzle yesterday right
and all of a sudden it was in a snowy
area snow was coming down I'm playing on
performance mode when it started
I broke the kid really yes there was
there was snow coming down I was in the
middle of a puzzle and I don't know what
happened but it was a good like 20
seconds while I'm like it's pretty long
yeah it it just couldn't catch up you're
playing in in performance okay yeah well
it was the SSD it was cold this weekend
it needed time to heat up and then it
saw snow it was like it was it was
a phobia snow
so I'm yeah I'm I'm enjoying it more and
more I I'm not even remotely close to
done obviously yeah no way to go that's
a long game yeah yeah but I've been
doing it it took me like 40 hours to
beat yeah I remember he was Blazing
Android
of course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the access gamer
the profit of Xbox
nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement
beloved Lord King how are we doing sir
snug is a bug
so yo this cold ain't got a thing on me
yo last night Alicia bumgarden was
fighting so she was fighting for the
Undisputed uh champ uh title did very
well so shout out to you queen that was
a fantastic fight I was not going to
stream it because it was on the zone and
the Zone always have
mismatch lopsided fights I knew Alicia
was going to go in there and win it
wasn't no uh thought of oh my God she
might lose tomato can of the week yeah
that's so sad in this time where you
want to get the most for your dollar a
lot of these promoters aren't doing that
so you know the zone is probably the top
ranking official in giving you tomato
cans of the month stuff oh damn you know
follow closely uh by top rank
um I just believe that showtime in the
PVC
yeah you know Bob damn I've been out the
game and I remember that was Bob yo
listen shout out to Bob arum and Don
King for still being the
longest running a major promoters you
know because Don is still out there Don
is still reading promo star and Don is
still putting smaller cars together not
to a huge extent that he was doing it
before you know his son uh Carl King is
putting together stuff okay um but um
yeah so boxing was good this week what
you're doing I'm not gonna lie I got in
a lot of Gaming all right okay high five
rush I'm not gonna be like one of these
little Xbox dudes that's captain crazy
hard for the game oh
because they matter there's been so many
different things that I've been like
taking my attention from it okay so if
you go look and you'll be like oh he
didn't play too much of it no I really
didn't get a chance to because I ran
over to
um do some PlayStation stuff
what you was doing over there well
we're gonna get to the topic later I was
going to see all the stuff that was
released
I see what's going on okay okay because
you had heard so you wouldn't go see I
heard that you know the Street's about
to dry up
so you know these dudes over here like
yeah here's this but we taking it back
all right this this is what we got you
in with uh we'll be taking that back and
we will discuss when it gets to that
topic I was over there I was you know
touching some stuff but then I got on my
Xbox shout out to the Call of Duty
um
the single play of the campaign yeah
okay okay now
I don't like how Call of Duty is set up
they should have a a like a side you can
just do your campaign the screen is so
convoluted yeah
what's going on and then campaign is
down in the corner in the bottom yes
come come down here for this all this
everything that you see up there is
multiplayer crap and I I hate y'all
multiplayer you never do both of them is
garbage it's hot trash like it's the
worst it is the shoot him twice he died
respawn repeat shoot him twice
it is true for that it is so garbage it
is there's no skill involved and you do
be acting like man I got the scar I was
litty
with the sky yo you stupid
let us literally luck you got the drop
if you got the drop you've got to drop
it's on that's it but other than that
hot garbage wow I'm so sick and tired of
it again it's it's trash single player
lit the hardest thing to play it's crazy
I was like yo I was looking in the water
I was doing stealth stuff I was like oh
isn't true going into people house
putting on the night vision yeah so much
fun killing the murking and murder more
than the one shot kill a dealer
that y'all like but you like Warzone
though right
not really oh yeah
nobody got this multiplayer old school
like Prestige all that one shot
I thought you would like that it's like
pubg but with the better graphics nah
you know what I do like fortnite I know
I guess we know we know you for a night
into a skill based game because it's
really skill involved there's so many
different things that they added with
the perks I do like having you know uh
attic on we was playing with Cat Daddy
last night and this game really
perpetuates the thought of Higher Ground
like if you got Higher Ground if you got
Advantage nine times out of ten you keep
them at distance it's it's probably one
of the most intricate dances that you
can play
if you do something wrong one thing can
jeopardize your whole team because they
throw stuff in the frenzy So Dope Game I
love that game having fun with it I was
playing uh a couple of other things and
then you know my son gets here and he's
just PlayStation junkie now oh yeah like
what you said converse
and I love it I love it because I told
him you know he's in the car it's like
Oh Daddy yeah you know the PlayStation
and so I come up to eat we sitting down
at the table getting ready to eat he
goes I gotta make a confession dad
bloodborne sucks oh I said uh I told you
that before
why you don't like my boy I said uh
because he gonna tell me it was no flash
he so like for this the souls games I
said oh there's no Elden ring right son
he's like yes it's not like I said I
told you none of them is like it
I said yeah but I said you know when you
can play elderly it's a flask and blood
bumper you gotta buy it you know it just
doesn't keep replenishing he doesn't
like it
he said this game
wow
wow that's crazy I said you want to play
Demon Souls on the PlayStation 5
downstairs he said I would love to so I
said go ahead go knock that out so you
go downstairs Daddy
oh damn I said yeah I said um so Elder
ring is King right oh yes Dad
I said
I said we'll play basketball
oh here we go with the influence man get
yourself back in the food
but he likes catching you know um he
likes collecting all the book bags he
got all the book bags of Spider-Man so
your boy after my own heart I told him
yeah
if it ain't no hot weapon the hot thing
he ain't doing I don't care about that
it's even worse if you don't tell me I'm
even gonna get it like I won't even do
it unless you tell me you gotta show you
what the reward is I have to I okay
sometimes you know I might someone might
say yo there's some hot thing you get
when you do this okay I'll go do it but
if you don't come out and say yo this is
what you're gonna get well I'm gonna
assume it's it's going to be dogs like
nah I ain't doing it like seven there's
too many times I've done something and
got something completely useless it's
doing a side quest and some of them be
stupid long to do go get side quests go
throw 300 rocks at owls like
you tell me that's why I like certain
there are games that they like look like
this is what it is this is what you
gonna get okay I ain't doing you like
thanks for telling me I'm not telling
you I'm Savage but I told him I said um
he's like uh so it's Spider-Man 2 coming
out you know I said yeah man don't worry
about it it'll be there I said just keep
playing
you playing your PlayStation 4 the more
Sony looks over and say hey yo oh we
back on that we gotta make games over
there for them too
I see what's going on number dictate who
rocked the place though I like that I
mean that's all I've been doing you know
having fun all this week playing with
attic almost every day pause you know in
fortnite
yeah I was I was about to say King just
bend the knee already but it's okay I
got patience
listen my sons yeah I'm about to take
your knees
worth more than you trying to win a bet
Sony don't let the kids of America down
yeah
because he played Miles Morales too you
thought that couldn't happen you saw
that repeat we
[Laughter]
need that on that fool baby we gonna see
what happened with that baby it would be
very interesting we'll be interested
it's gonna be interesting we're gonna
talk we're gonna talk about some things
addict later we're gonna talk about some
things anyway and of course we have the
game with it himself the Shinobi low
incognito's friend that run into the
ramen IOP not telling what you want to
have what you need here shout out to my
man Mr Maddie please shout out to Friday
dude how to forward some of this
something hilarious they got us like
recorded drunk it's absolutely hilarious
on the segment we did about haircuts but
anyway go check that out talk about
what's going on with the E3 situation
and all that
um shout out to the last word ebontist
uh was a throwback episode no tie guy
because he's been um working on a
undisclosed NDA uh game yeah so I can't
blow him up you know what I'm saying but
yeah he doing what he's doing but we had
a we took it back to flash Playing
remember we used to be cool
I can't say what it is you're still
working out I can't say what it is
happy you funny but yeah shout out to
him um but yeah many bosses had the old
school two-man joint like but we used to
be called Flashpoint before he scored
the last word so we talk about
everything that's going on with the
season yeah getting stuff done man it's
a good time to get in to get a lot of
like free weapons and stuff you missed
out on they're doing a lot of stuff to
kind of get you back again yeah they try
to get it they try to get it in you know
what I'm saying so as far as games
finish Crisis Core man that was good
that was really good I missed out on
that on PSP I'm embarrassed number King
I had PSP and we had almost all the
games I don't know how did I miss it I
got crisis it was it was a late PSP game
because I was talking to Maddie and I'm
like I'm like I am I think it came out
almost when the Vita came out thank you
because I'm like I'm such a PSP dude I'm
like how did I miss this game and I had
to feed it almost so it had to be
towards the end of the cycle because I
was like
yeah so that's what it is but yeah they
did that man so Xbox guys go out there
and go support it it's really good great
prequel to what's going on I really
didn't know about Zach and without
spoiling do you do you really want the
Xbox to go to supporter with the fact
that they didn't get uh Final Fantasy 7
remake well maybe if people go out and
support the crisis because no maybe
don't go buy that guys damn
well I would call for is I would call
for an all-out band on Square products
[Music]
with your buying power we ain't gonna
support your practices bro why don't we
show them without buying power that we
really want Crisis Core and give us the
rest of the game please by having the
numbers
like realistically do you believe that I
work yeah probably not yeah but it was
like
but if you got if you guys want to go
and support uh you know by the end
because you love it that's one thing but
don't buy the game under the assumption
that your cell is going to lead to the
other ones coming out because I don't
think it's all I would say it is I was
actually surprised crisis scores on Xbox
so to me their logic makes no sense
because if you're going to make not make
remake look to Sony drop the bag made an
exclusive I get it but to me then why
not keep everything off right why not
give up just say say is exclusive so
everybody can just be like move on from
the sun no I agree they need to be more
transparent on the exclusivity aspect
with Final Fantasy 7 remake I completely
agree but I was happy to see that I was
like oh wow this made made the cut like
why did this make the cut like it really
didn't feel that it was a mainstream
game possibly possibly they did probably
up the back but anyway long story short
great game and even though attic years
ago told me what eventually happens yeah
nothing prepared the kid
and I'm sitting there like
oh he's right
I was like not like this
so yeah and then if if we played uh I'm
a big remake guy so I played it ended on
um what you call a PS5 and then I mean
PS4 and then well I loaded it on my uh
the PS5 so
I'm about to you know you know dip down
anime into it oh okay
but anyway but uh yeah based on what
happens at the end I am so now
interested I'm glad that I caught up and
know what's going on because they're
doing something wild and I think there's
a reason that they release that game yes
I think it's all part of the rollout
there's a long-term tale so we'll see
what happens and hopefully uh fantasy
remake on PlayStation 5 and the end of
this year hopefully part two so we'll
see anyway doing that
um what's up
r r fans I have to address you guys
um what happened very shortly very just
what I've been watching right now um
that just consumed my life uh the record
of Ragnarok that's on Netflix season two
is out and you know wifey watch season
two with me so we we binge watched that
so I had to double back and show her the
you know season one so we're up to the
part where Odin is fighting Adam
and um yeah I mean not Odin um Zeus Zeus
is fighting Adam and yeah she she gets
to understand Adam's Power the first man
you know made
that is one anime I love that manui mono
stuff that is one anime if you haven't
watched anime and you're into the
fighting stuff
and you know Supernatural Powers Yeah
please check it out it's called Uh
record of Ragnarok it's on Netflix and
see y'all on Tuesdays at 5 p.m so we can
talk about it no doubt salute the r and
r what 515 in the chat right now please
hit that like button
say the puppy say children well it's two
platypus that we have
in Argentina last week so right now
we're we're going for the Indonesian
sloth
hit the like button
yes and here here's the YouTube channel
the r r if you guys don't yes you have
time to sit and watch like a whole
podcast these are just pretty much the
topics separated in their own videos
exactly yeah exactly
with the last of us and that's the most
views out of everything on that channel
right now is that argument that's what's
up that's what's up I mean because it's
that that it wasn't an argument it was a
view on yeah I was right you were wrong
well okay if you want to take that take
good
um but it was it was a views that we had
on the show looking from two different
eyes and you know attic came from a pure
standpoint of the game if you were doing
the game one-to-one and then you
drastically switch up that formula in
the third episode on a character that he
was looking forward to see uh done on a
one-on-one scale I can feel him right
but then from my from my aspect of it uh
I didn't remember said character I
didn't remember him at all from the game
and I played the game twice
so he was that uh forgettable to me but
I will never forget him now because of
this show right so it's a yiny Yang and
just I just think Neil druckman is other
jeans I can't wait to have him on the
show in a room yeah I will I will say
this I will say this I enjoyed the take
I I really did love what they kind of
feel they filled in the blanks right
okay but I will say this about the game
see the thing about the game version of
it is you since you have to fill in the
blanks yourself right it's left in a
point where this world is so unforgiving
that the somewhat kind of a happy ending
they got in the in the show is it's less
believable considering the extent of how
messed up this world is so the kind of
the way it resolves itself in the game
makes more sense with you know what in
this world you're not gonna get Happy
Endings this world's so Unforgettable uh
I mean this world is so unforgiving that
somehow they went 20 years and didn't
have that place invaded one time oh here
we go anyway so you can catch that on r
r right there yeah yeah yeah yeah
no you don't you talk about all y'all
like Carl was just talking about Final
Fantasy
I just like sometimes
so so so so Cog so [__] the game came
out 2007 right for the PSP yeah PSP like
it kind of reached this in 2008 or nine
they you know they they did the PSP 3000
like the cheaper version and then they
went with the PSP Go which didn't really
do all that well but they really stopped
they only stopped really shipping PSPs
in like 20 14 to 16 something like that
so there was PSP shipping but you know
after a certain point it was just a
bootleg machine yeah everybody you know
so it kind of was at the tail end of
when it was relevant as a machine where
people were literally going out and
buying games for it facts
um so yeah I guess it was I guess by
that time we had moved on because I had
I didn't play it yeah enough salute to
them but they they what they did is they
now remade that combat to how Final
Fantasy VII remake is and the combat is
phenomenal the summons are phenomenal
the material Fusion is outstanding they
got this DMW it's almost like little
slot machine where you see the faces of
the characters and if three of them
happen then you get a little cinematic
sometimes it's a summon Sometimes some
of the characters you meet and then what
I like is that you are meeting the
characters
where they were like Zach is meaning
characters we love at a time in their
life where it's different you've seen a
young teefer you see the cloud for the
first time like the way they bought like
I'm not saying useless clouds yeah like
you're like damn Cloud was really whack
right like yeah you realize Zach was
that dude you know what I'm saying and
then you know I don't spoil too much but
there's moments and then like I said
because you now get attached to
everything exact fear and then the way
it ends you just like yo so I can't wait
to see now what this very bold situation
that's happened at the end of remake
where this universe is going because
like I'm I'm getting that as soon as so
I'm caught up I'm all I got all my Lord
I'm ready to go so that's been that
obviously we're doing Destiny 2 and then
obviously this is the week I'm gonna
really knock out and spend all my
attention now on hi-fi rush and get that
going so that's been it for me but as
far as I get the super chats off yeah
yeah oh real quick the king didn't
mention this for the boxing but shout
out to LA
was there any real doubt in that fight
no no no no
the only reason why I said Alicia
bumgarden because at least that fight it
was yes it was it was a fight
this is not a fight yeah it's a bad
boxing talk today anyway let me get let
me get this
all right uh I'm assuming this is uh oh
damn
I know who this is oh hell the IOP
salute the Lord shout out to the chap uh
great to see everyone have a great show
let's go why can I not remember this
man's name right now okay it wouldn't
let me copy the name but it was
something in the way yeah but I know who
you are you know thank you why can't I
remember your name right now can't
remember your name because we know who
you are absolute remember for one year
five dollars Super Chat hmm I don't
remember y'all dedicating an entire
topic to Pokemon selling 10 million in
three days and being the fastest selling
exclusive ever hashtag media advice
listen yeah you got it right though you
got it right
I said uh you have to have a uh
performance required before we do that
like bro listen my nephew who does not
care a damn about performance was like
deal like it's it it it it like it
stutters
no no he ain't talking about it before
actually he was like I was like did you
finish up a Pokemon Scarlet yeah he was
like nah stopped I was playing I was
playing some other stuff I go back and
forth and I'm like really because he
usually devours the game in like a day
or two and he was like it just like it's
jumping a little bit and I'm like oh my
God he started to think about Graphics
now as well wow that's crazy and he's
like hey um can I have an Xbox series at
all
don't get him all that stuff so you know
that's crazy shout out to run away
Dragon TV Brooklyn
yeah we got let's put the crust in the
chapel Lord's Braun reload bronze Raiden
blade remember for one year shout out
sir
then we have necromancers they'll
remember for one year ten dollar Super
Chat looking forward to a lord Sovereign
stream of playing dead space remake how
do we make it happen uh you make it
happen by Sav actually being home which
doesn't happen ever but I would love to
I would love to because I wanna I wanna
see how it differs from the original but
yeah it ain't happening and we got
sanjitsu Sage haven't seen Sage for a
minute remember for 21 months
he was
[Music]
uh the beta Boys video is hilarious
hello Lords high five Russian straight
fire and one of the greatest games I
have ever played in my life oh God it is
that special of a game give that game
its flowers yeah he was mad at me boy
yeah shout out to Hi-Fi Rush there high
five Rush gang was mad at me why why was
it mad at you Jess put out a tweet and
was like name
one take that Xbox fans will be mad at
you so you know what I had to say you
know hashtag just one Triple A
experience Pro High Fidelity Graphics
strong narrative so you felt that that
wasn't it no I didn't even talk about
you know I want to hashtag just one new
IP right so then the hi-fi
Hi-Fi Rush bro exists bro and I'm just
like okay that's not it though that's
cool for you God bless that's cool yeah
I love it I love it I love it too but it
don't hit all noodles in my criteria
that's all I was saying oh no so Sage
was in there it was a couple over there
it was getting bad and I'm just sitting
there I'm like that's nice that's your
list that don't quantify football you
know what you know I understand exactly
what you're talking about it's more of a
platformer it's not what you want no no
it it's it's not even really a
platformer it has some parts I would
consider it more of like a Bayonetta
kind of game like combat wise like it
focuses more on that than anything oh
I'm saying part of the criteria is like
you see how like hellblade 2 would be
considered everything
and then a hashtag just what is just
that it's a sequel to the already
existing game right now what I was
explaining to people which being Sage
agreed on which was Quant like when we
talked about Xbox one generation
of Rome is a hashtag just one yeah
Quantum break is a hashtag
new IP hot third person perspective High
graphical Fidelity you know what I'm
saying when you see it you go oh my God
that the system
hello hello me and me and Sage bonded on
that and that's what we all we kind of
we all met in the middle but it was a
fun I was surprised to see my response
get all distraction and mad people eat
mostly agreed but it was interesting it
was like a little thing going on in the
community so the hashtag just one fight
is still is still going on you know what
I'm saying but salute to high five Rush
she already knows bad love you already
know but good to you what else we got
solved hold on a second yeah give me one
moment and that was Gerald Mack by the
way my apologies I'm like I know this
man his name is oh yeah yeah you didn't
have to Super Chat that you could just
put it in the channel yo he super
chatted yeah
that's
my dude he's in there you know rain
sleep side like he's dead always always
blank the name I'm like I know who this
is why I got my blank in the name Joe
Mack the homie thank you brother oh we
got 22 we got 22 for the paxies let's go
oh we get it let me let me tell you
something for the paxies merch guys for
everybody because those shirts is in the
store right now right now we're going to
pack seats
don't try to run up on us
in
it's gonna be a little exclusive
something for those shirt dudes like we
see that
that's that's rocking okay I put in the
the uh the chat straight to that shirt
so yeah look at that shirt and uh go uh
pick up a Pax East ticket you know you
might there might be something else here
soon listen even if you don't get a Pax
East ticket what I would really like
don't even go to packs don't you be
outside with the shirts on with with
picket signs
and we'll come over to the crowd don't
even worry about packs worry about us
we'll be there and we'll do something
out in the front with those news and
then you know people that's inside packs
but you know we'll handle that too but
this shirt is the key and it's
definitely necessary you're gonna see
why it's necessary as we get closer to
it but I do like that uh 22
22.88 that's what's up I love it thank
you 25 we hit our first uh goal well
that's all we need we need to get to the
first goal so y'all can where's the goal
list at it it's on that
um I have to bring it up man let me see
what it looked like because I think they
must have forgot
Roy Jones
sir yep I got him hold on a second then
we got himanshu yada with the 40 rupee
Super Chat is the news about CMA
blocking the ABK deal true I don't think
it's blocking it they have they have
formal concerns okay and they have to be
addressed that's what it is after I've
seen those financials I was like look
like somebody mighty fine on the hog
than me
and uh okay and speaking of Roy Jones
and Manchu yada up again with the 40
rupees Super Chat did you guys try
Undisputed the new boxing game that's
not that's on Steam bro it's on Steam I
will be I'll be as soon as I get my
computer in I will be trying that I'm
not doing nothing on this thing get your
Steam on my Xbox all right and then I'll
see what I do over there but it looks
every okay everybody's in my beautiful
asking me am I blown away by this game
no I'm not
yeah right I'm Blown Away by the roster
I'm blown away that somebody said okay
we're gonna go and dig out an old
PlayStation 3 Graphics type of game
um that's what it looks like to me the
first time we saw all right round three
it was it was it was me and Cog yes and
it was Roy and Bernard oh Jesus Christ I
still say that first one the first one
yeah graphically graphically was
different bro it was completely
different then when you know the other
ones they I don't know they they kind of
did the graphics I don't feel like it
regressed a little bit yeah it didn't
right yeah I thought it was just me I'm
glad you said that you know what it is
it was the overall animations improved
but the but the grat you know they
focused on the close-ups yeah where you
would where you were like uh you were
like taking care of the different cuts
in the different parts and stuff in
between rounds so they focused on I mean
that game sold a lot of people on that
360. oh for sure that was like okay I'm
getting a 360.
edible yeah and so this joint is in line
with the the afterwards like but not the
first one the first one graphic and I
want to get back to that like I wanted
that to expound okay this thing it
looked like a really nice PlayStation 3
game okay and the animations still look
like we stuck in 92 or something so
y'all can sit there and be capping all
you want to when the punch goes
[Music]
more like dead sense
wow wow messy messy messy messy and we
got Kaya Santi five dollar Super Chat
salute to the Lords on a great Sunday oh
special shout out to King David I see
you brother keeping the beard game all
Natty Oh Daddy it is about time
listen so I've been shamed me into just
leaving just for a minute
[Laughter]
you know I got to respect my guy to um
[Music]
salute to the Lords on this warmer than
yesterday Sunday yes definitely warmer
had a low of uh minus 11 Fahrenheit
yesterday yes that was about right minus
12. it's near 50 degrees today let's
hope Hogwarts is good yes reviews come
out tomorrow so we will see
we should see we shall see and it will
be
left we have Aldrich uh 5118 five
dollars chat Xbox Gamers shouldn't buy
anything from Square Enix let them die
with Sony Jesus
I'm sure attic agrees with you though I
mean I don't want so like Square Enix to
like cease to exist I just want them to
stop doing the dumb stuff they'd be
doing
watch your mouth I see you in it talking
slick keep it up keep your body off with
your head I see you here talking slick
watch it dude continue so yeah Randy G
10 super chat it's a very stupid move by
square to put ff16 exclusively on PS5
that's their biggest game they could
potentially have Elden ring numbers if
the game hit they may lose a lot of
potential sales let's try to get to us
someday
see and we have gaming forts hey
remember for 37 months Lord bronze thank
you brother glad to be back in the realm
of the Lords truly missed you guys plus
king killing it with that black mink
and as always hey King Boo Boo hey
thank you sir it's cold as hell outside
yeah it looks crazy I'm in the basement
yeah that's where it was real then we
got Hollywood rules remember for 12
months Lord silver happy IOP Sunday to
my NYC and West Virginia cousins best
part on YouTube have a great pot guys
thank you brother salute to the West
Virginia love I like that fat absolutely
hell yeah I'm in Virginia thank you
everywhere
West Side yo you yellow west side west
side but why you got clay hold on we got
to get it why are you not claiming that
I'm I'm literally in Virginia
I would call Zach let me call Zach I'm
gonna find out
your brother ain't claiming West Side
bro
I want to continue
then we got Mandingo mcdickins
that's messed up King he acted like the
NBA I save up to go see you guys and
can't see you because of a shirt we talk
about a shirt not a game not a game but
a shirt
get him King beam Hollywood hey hey you
got enough time get that shirt but the
lady Link's in description
at the top
go get that
and then we held on we go back to the
regular chat we got done a taco five
dollar super tap according to uh digital
Foundry Hi-Fi Rush is some of the best
graphics of the Year bend the knee Cog
hashtag just one bruh this best graphics
look it's beautiful it's it's a great
art style it's a great you know it's a
great showpiece salute but we talk about
realistic High Fidelity Graphics it
ain't that that's all I'm trying to say
you want the penal pill I wanna I wanna
see what the city
that's what platinum in fact over did
facts he's absolutely right Paul it is a
phenomenal game Xbox one no doubt on the
fact that they kept it under wraps all
this time is is kind of crazy you know
what I like to hear I I hear now people
were like yeah I told y'all that they
was working on to get shut up
James jason Hackett hellblade 2 cannot
be a just one it's a sequel told you new
IP new IP no the new joints they got new
joints coming guys yeah
yeah then we have the sage [__]
four pound and 49 Pence Super Chat love
to the realm and the Lord you guys are
fired thank you brother appreciate it
member for 27 months my apologies once
again brother shout out to Lord King
David for keeping Silver Fox bed in
Pocket all hail to aisle piece salute
thank you thank you the great silver
foxes
no doubt and we got ko3 black truth two
dollar Super Chat
ba stand up seven five seven game
[Laughter]
jason Hackett have vow does not count
it's not third person I'm Gonna Give You
All the Rules cause y'all keep he'd be
like he's expanding he's keep changing
but no it's always been I'm gonna give
y'all the rules and if you ever put
tweet up that I said cause y'all don't
understand y'all cannot read look look
look at Last of Us look at ghost of
sushima that's it look look at look at
look at Quantum break look at Rise Son
Of Rome please understand the rules I'm
gonna give it to y'all because y'all
Quantum break yeah continue
then we have Robert Kelly two dollar
Super Chat Cog wants high five of us
see what that moving door you see what
the HBO doing
people see like it
then we got magic thinkings two dollars
of attack what about Forza [__]
that was funny all right that was good
we have uh void lock member for 13
months Lord bronze let Square go in the
bushes Hi-Fi Rush is a better game than
Sonic forgot forgotten West and four
broken
not necessary okay for you we get to the
God of War numbers I'm gonna talk to
y'all let's go I'm gonna talk to you
that's it we are caught up all caught up
hold on one second I'll be added didn't
we have something we had to announce
real quick before we get into the
tournament but we have some
announcements did I have internet no no
attic oh oh yeah so we for those that's
in the chat we did restructure uh our
patreon we we're we're still working on
everything uh but we did do the initial
restructure uh so pretty much we have
added to the tiers uh We've added to the
five dollar tier that you could ask
every podcast that we have we'll have a
segment at the beginning of every show
where you can ask us questions uh you
know generally try to keep your gaming
related because we will won't be
answering all of them obviously because
we already go five hours we're not
trying to extend all that but we will be
answering a couple questions every week
from um from the patreon on every show
so that means r r uh the attic show
combat talk and I IOP will be answering
questions uh we also have a the seven
dollar chair we put could mean King
doing r r so we kind of put a little bit
of r r in there where the seven dollar
tier you can watch reactions of me and
King do stuff so for instance
um King is watching Attack on Titan
right now so you know you will have some
of that up there I'm reacting currently
to a chainsaw man uh the first episode's
already on the patreon so if you want to
see me react to the first episode of
Chainsaw man uh you can go over there
and catch that and then we have the ten
dollar tier where you could choose what
we react to uh so I saw a lot of people
asking yo react to this react to that we
don't got time for all that but if you
want you can go to the page sure I'll go
on the 10 tier and uh you know we will
get to it uh we'll try to get to it
every month like obviously that tier
gets too ridiculous we'll have to
restructure in some way but right now uh
for for for the now we could pretty much
get to anyone we need to uh what I'm
going to what I'm going to do is put the
patreon in the chat uh so definitely go
click on that you know we we have a lot
of uh stuff there for you guys now we're
about to read the first set of questions
anyone jump right into that I'm gonna do
the pull then jump into it but I could
do it yeah yeah that's fine no just do
the ball real quick all right cool let's
get to the poll last week's poll results
the end of people have spoken to the
question with the initial positive
response and reviews regarding Hi-Fi
Rush how do you want Xbox to continue
momentum in 2023 the winner of our
four-way ILP poll with 47 of the vote
was commit to Quality for all their
games regardless of delays a lot of soft
talk energy kick they want
second place with 20 of the vote was
more stealth launches and surprises at
Xbox Advanced group in third place with
a close 18 of the vote was commit to
their release date promises and hit them
consistently that's that gangster list
group that
18.6 the list was in the 18 and then
last place 14 of the vote was I don't
care I need my star feel or else group
Lord addict on I think the the realm
agrees with us uh quality over um you
know I mean there's only one way
yeah my way we want the game to be the
best it possibly can be and uh you know
what listen hitting your days don't mean
that the game gonna be the best it
possibly can be I mean it can't be any
worse stop equating them hitting their
Mark and being professional with low
quality oh we leave it an extra seven
months
as if it won't do anything
this is for the majority of people out
there and you guys can really you know
like feel what I'm saying if you have an
employee and stuff like that anytime you
know that you have extra time on
something how many times do you BS I'll
get to it at tomorrow I get to that
tomorrow but when you have a hard
deadline because I see it all the time
dudes have a heart yo this game got to
come out tomorrow so you know I'm just
tightening up some stuff over here
because I'm working real hard but when
they got extra seven months they like
yeah okay I can get to that code today
and uh I'll leisurely do this no you got
a hard deadline you said you was going
to do something get to it and get it
done that doesn't mean that it's not
going to be less polished or more
polished later it's get a quality game
out in time it has nothing to do with
that so don't twist my words talking
about I want a Half Baked game out
tomorrow they better hit it that's what
you said they better they better hit
their date so they better been working
okay think about it this way
if that game and I swear to God there's
no coming back from it right I
officially need this Advanced Eugene to
take this
yeah good good drink it up
if that goes if they say okay we ship in
November and that game come out in
November and it's not finished finish
like you find some bugs or something you
ain't coming back from that Jake I like
I'm that that really don't make no sense
so if it wasn't ready in November What's
it gonna look like
you don't know if it's ready now but you
don't either exactly but but but this is
what I'm saying
I don't believe the state and Saul said
it [__] ship broken regardless whenever
they dropped
so if they dropped today or they dropped
two months from now they gonna still
shipping machine same state right you
have no idea what state is going to be
two weeks ain't gonna make no difference
bro we made two weeks ain't gonna make a
difference but six months
man I don't care when it yo I know he
don't care he don't he don't care about
the quality of the game June if you're
not coming out in June I'm gonna switch
this focus on you
I'm gonna switch this focus on you well
looks like the realm agrees with us and
they were
oh but all is said done
regardless
shout out to our 47 of you
I'm gonna be a messy I'll be completely
messy let me stop I'm very extra today
I'm sorry all right so um now we gotta
like Lord uh mention we got our patreon
question shout out to scrub nurse he
said with some people saying Xbox 2023
year is a fail if we only see the games
that were delayed come out this year
redfall Starfield Falls the water sport
does hi-fi Rush surprise drop and all
its accolades be good enough let's start
with kid because that that's a lot of
talk going on right now people are
saying yo if they if it's just to
delayed games from 2022 and 2023 is a
year but now that high five Rush coming
nobody know about it is it is it good
enough or how do you feel it's 2023 a
fail if it's just the um those the games
that got delayed for 2022. they're not
doing that I mean
um those games was pushed back because
they were dancing in the mirror to
themselves to their own tune
and um I think that I think honestly
they was looking at certain things to be
finalized and done right and then they
go over there and
for for sovereign's take for my take
those those games were Todd worthy like
times like they finished I'll get them
out the door
they got to do something extra they
can't just bring the leftovers from last
year it was held over to this year and
think that's going to encapsulate a
great year no that was something that
you were supposed to bring over anyway
get those games out that you have from
the last E3 in the 12 months that you
said show us the next 12 months plan
what I don't want them to do
is get to this E3 and be like okay well
we're gonna switch the format up again
no
you said 12 months now let's rock this
12 months because I guess now they
really seen how how hard 12 months is if
you put that on your head like that's on
your dock if everything in this show got
to come out in 12 months and I push uh
on um unnecessary burden on your back
because you're forced to to get these
games without in that year right I
thought it was good everybody was like
no that's bad because we don't get a
chance to see the future
I thought it was good in the fact that
it forces these guys to stay in Pocket
not to worry about oh we could show
Faith No keep your eyes on the damn
prize these are the games that has to
get done and then the next six months
we'll show you the next games that we're
gonna come out with or from next show or
the next 12 months we'll show you the
you know the games at the next E3
do it in that way and it forces
productivity I think productivity is the
problem with Microsoft when it comes to
everything else and equality so they can
focus on these games that's all just but
if they try that oh these are the games
from last year and this is all you're
going to get for this year now I'm not
about that okay no I want the new 12 I
want the new 12 months of Christmas list
okay you're a fan of attic when you act
with this do you think it's an L do you
think they've already um broken the fact
that it's not going to be out with Hi-Fi
rush if it's the same games that were
delayed from 2022. it just depends on
what they are if these games come out
and hit that's all they need if they
don't they're gonna need more you know
if Starfield comes out wow is everybody
if hell blade come not hellblade redfall
comes out Wows everybody then
I honestly in Forza comes out Wows
everybody like that's four games and
then obviously Minecraft it's just it
just depends on how they hit I don't
think it's going to be all I I do think
you have an entire holiday of 2023 to
account for and most likely they're not
going to just leave that blank but you
know that is to be seen in a couple
months but as of right now it just
depends on the quality and how these
games come out if they do good then I
think people will shut up obviously
ain't everyone but you ain't gonna some
people your facts facts no doubt no
doubt launch solve is it an L just the
2022 lineup or does hi-fi rush change
your feeling according to scrubblers no
we had this conversation I think at some
point before and I was like you know I
mean you can't the game didn't come out
last year so it's like you can't you
can't hold it to that anymore it's just
that's like holding up the game
PlayStation for last year because God of
War got pushed to 2022. uh all them
games got pushed to 2022. remember when
return on all them got delayed to 2021
Microsoft been popping out all these
fantastic AAA titles oh that's fine and
they can get a a lady back no man you
can't rest on nothing you ain't got no
morals like there's no Laurels for you
to sit down and be like we did that okay
that's when they got three other games
they got three other games ready they
shouldn't space those out and just none
of them all in the Batman I'm saying
that y'all using this argument like Sony
Sony earned that like let's keep it a
buck Sony earned you to shut up like
damn we dropping this when we drop it
okay they can do that uh-huh right
because you're all safe well when it
come out though it's gonna be quality
yeah for sure but what happened to the
Game Pass buffer what happened I'm not
saying that I'm not saying that what I'm
saying is what I'm hearing is aha you
guys talking about like Microsoft earned
some some they didn't earn nobody ever
nothing I didn't say earned anything
come out of my mind use those words you
didn't use those words right but what
I'm saying is
oh we don't hold Sony or Nintendo those
little same um criterias
they earned the fact the whole act they
earned it Microsoft didn't when they can
build up a cachet when it can drop at
least five high five rushes in a row I
feel like you know they can build up
that case we can say okay cool down we
we all right okay when they do drop is
dope
no I'm just saying that they don't get
the benefit of the doubt that Sony does
right so when when you see something
like and I'm not going to use I got to
use for spoken but it's not theirs this
is what I'm saying when they when they
started dropping broken games you start
seeing stuff come out then you can
question like wow what's going on over
here yeah all right release the joints
too early okay something's up over there
but y'all still say well you know they
bangers though everybody still say but
they but there's they Studios their
Studios is gonna be five
Microsoft has to release their AAA
titles
and it's in a way that gives them that
cache they haven't done it so that's why
they held to a different standard that's
why scrutiny is always going to be
looked at their way until they release
games that can consistently be in that
Metacritic score of 90s always
that's that's when they earn that that
oh they can be identified differently
but right now you heard you'll hold to a
different standard we don't trust you
like that these other dudes they've been
producing good quality stuff we can give
them the benefit of the doubt and it
sucks but until y'all get to that level
then we're gonna keep holding you in in
the spotlight that's right stitches mad
at [__] I mean okay he said Cog take the
gummies away from kids they bad but
anyway now but most agree but continues
oh so I'll finish you get your yes
because I just feel like you know every
time I speak yeah
both of them when you talk your IPS they
IPS yeah IPS is crazy
I say all the things that they don't get
to say yeah like for whatever reason
they all in your topic yeah you know
what's funny though no you say people in
the chat they won't talk about King
interrupting they'll just talk about me
no but I
I see where King's coming from I see
where that is coming from my thing is
this
all of this stuff about you don't have
there's no you don't have the cash in
you can't get away end of the day
if they they need to spread these games
out we already saw what happens I used
to have the same argument where it's
like you know what everything in Game
Pass is additive it doesn't matter when
it drops not true not true because at
the end of the day all of these games
need their moment they need their
moments so if you tell me that there's x
amount of games ready to go at the end
of this year
and they're going to hold them back for
next year in order to spread stuff out
more remember everything is backed up
everything is still backed up you
understand like we just because we we
get a release Cadence now doesn't mean
that they still aren't games that are
somewhat backed up from before like
coping messed everybody up for a good
couple of years right we're not going to
see a regular Cadence for a while so for
me
if this is what it is and we still get
the star feel we still get the forza and
we still get the the red fall and we got
high five Rush In addition to the stuff
that's kind of exclusive to Game Pass
coming out as lies of P well long stuff
like that I'm good with that I can't be
mad at them for for not re not being
able to stick to a date they had for
last year and all of a sudden now it's
an old game because
I can't do it like I can't to me
do whatever
if you have two more games at the end of
the year they're ready to go and you
feel the need to do it cool because
again last year was Baron so I
understand that from a certain point of
view but at the same time you give me
four games and like Alex said if they're
bangers if they're all of them hit
85 Plus Metacritic all of them
do they need to give us another one and
not to mention they're gonna be dropping
game past the whole year
in the game pass offers I said the Game
Pass offerings are kind of wild bro like
atomic heart is is coming up soon Eliza
P lies of P replaced uh what else
man would be the show Monster hunts that
we we just got
um so there's plenty of stuff yeah well
long exactly so it's just like I don't
know I don't feel that need
um and when you if you're gonna compare
it to last year it's night and day so uh
to me I don't know I wouldn't be mad at
them if this is them getting their
bearings this evening like these are the
games that are coming out make sure we
hit right make sure the game's equality
especially start for you right I'm not
worried about the turn ten I'm not
redfall I'm not really worried I'm
worried about how it will be received as
opposed to the quality of the game right
it's just one of those things like
Arcane games that are arcaney right are
is not going to appeal to everybody so
hopefully the vampire stuff helps and
brings people in and The Game Pass
buffer right the fact that you can just
try it so I don't know man thank you to
me I it's not an L to me if they give me
more fantastic but it it wouldn't be
alphabet not for you I mean I'll finish
up quick um kind of in the same pocket I
think that what it is is that now that
we know people know that the 2022 games
are going to come to 2023 then it's like
well that's it you know same kind of
thing and I get it you know by the end
of the day game game releases don't work
like that and and here's the thing if
you release these games right let's just
say hypothetically
2022 did happen redfall Starfield
dropped and then there was a 2023 lineup
That was ready to go right at the end of
the day those stuff's gonna get pushed
back anyway even if they were still
ready because you can't have them
compile and stack on top of each other
you know what I'm saying so you would
cannibalize your own releases and that's
the good problem to have that's the good
problem that's when you like okay
because it is maybe now we get at the
end of the year that hellblade that we
will talk about you know what I'm saying
because now everything is lining up the
way it may line up whether it be Forza
later in the year Starfield maybe the
middle of the year you know we got the
red four or whatever whatever so Hi-Fi
Rush already broke the answer to me
Hi-Fi Rush coming out being dominant
successful this great surprise
already sure was crazy they held Hi-Fi
rush but they we were killing them that
they had enough for 2022. it was easily
shut us up and be like yo shut up we got
this Banger right here shut up right
they took Tomatoes when they knew they
had stuff I mean they started right
before they come out they sat there or
high five so you know what we got so
that shows to me they've already got a
plan because if I Rush wouldn't have
stopped that Onslaught high five arrest
regardless to what anybody says high
five Rush is not a triple a banger but
hit but then but the numbers even though
it doesn't make hashtag just one
criteria the numbers to proceed I mean
based on these early Things based on the
revenue they made and Estelle dropped no
promotion like they're in the top four
or five of Stephen whatever it is okay
at a lower price point we can't deny the
success of Hi-Fi Rush okay I I think
this oh I think it was a perfect storm
okay all right and The Perfect Storm was
cultivated from the fact of the absence
that was made in uh 2023 I mean 2022.
right so there's a void there right and
there's an angry fan base that was like
yo what the hell are you working on but
then there was a show that we knew that
was coming inside June right right and
in that show they said there was only
going to be four games right so the fact
that we got the oh snap they doing some
they doing some theatrics yeah type of
thing
also it's a very polished game it was a
strategic gamble that actually paid off
price wise timing wise
absolutely absolutely right if they
would have gave it to us last year in
the place of Starfield let's just say
here you go take this we don't have
Starfield but take this same game
without all the stealth dropping all
this other stuff no I get where you're
going not even like okay not even not
even if they stealth drop it at the game
awards yeah the game was yeah they could
have they could have got good faith no I
don't I we've been saying this
and this is attic's point and I had to
come around to addicts point right much
they don't show as I say yo use Jeff
use Jeff's platform use his people
you need to build your own stuff facts
end up being right right and he's he
he's right yeah you build you build your
own stuff there and then when you have
something that you feel that is a
throwaway but it's noteworthy enough to
get the uh certain eyes on it or give it
to Jeff and put it on Jeff joint right
and let that Marketplace
no I'm smiling you know what I'm saying
I don't know what's going on what's
Happening never mind I'll get to it okay
okay no the last thing look I I feel
again just that Hi-Fi Rush already broke
the bowl and I do think I think both of
us are going to get what we want the yes
you know King is going to get I feel
games that are not that that were
outside of the 2022 lineup that we
didn't know about and we go oh and
that's going to quiet them and then for
us we get yo I'm glad they waited and
look oh my God hopefully you know star
feels amazing reform is amazing and then
everybody's happy because you get to do
and oh so I think both of us argument
it's going to end up panning out the way
both of us want it but we just got to
see but I was going to say about that
last one because we got to get the
second one we didn't get it dip down
games and Anime if you became the CEO of
Nintendo overnight due to reasons what
would be your first order of business
personally I'd kill Mario sick of that
dude people want to talk about ash from
Pokemon never going Mario should be at
least being a wheel Champion now sorry
for being messy all right you're the
president of Nintendo solve what you
doing
the president of Nintendo
I just damn what the hell am I doing the
president said though I'm moving them to
the 21st Century Fox just fight just get
off like I listen and they can stick to
the way they sell games because it works
for them it just works for them I'm
Gonna Keep it a buck to me
I don't even worry so much about the
hardware man like
definitely definitely Hardware that
isn't just at the cusp of where they're
gonna make money because all they care
about is making money on the hardware
from the rip they don't they never want
to lose money on Hardware not even a
week so
at least be at the cusp of where
technology is right and beyond that sell
your games do what you want to sell them
don't be everywhere be closed off the
way you are because it works for you I
don't think if there's anything we've
learned about what Nintendo was
competing right once once Xbox was in
the picture is that the it's very hard
for the market to support three
platforms that are kind of identical
right the GameCube is a testament to
that right that's why they went a
different way with the with the Wii so
they're good keep doing the hybrid thing
that is your lane don't deviate from it
though King and I don't believe that you
are gonna aren't gonna deviate from it
because it's Nintendo they're liable to
do something else and just throw money
in the toilet
um but for me yeah just online stuff I
agree with y'all just just let's bring
it to the 21st century in that regard
and and stop and and I would stop being
acting hateful towards your fans
we want anybody else to know about this
game no it's only the way we say like
all that stuff is just kind of
ridiculous it's it's it's so dumb and I
think in a lot of ways that's why you
start losing older gamers
because of that stuff right the younger
younger kids whatever they're still
gonna play Nintendo games but the older
game is if you if you do stuff like that
think about you know what whatever I get
for my kids I want no parts of this so
just bringing them forward in a way
where they still feel appealing to
everyone they'll say that I'm curious
attic what does Nintendo need to do
you're the president
uh
I think that the biggest thing
that they can do is like it's it's like
what it's like what Saul said is
upgrade a little bit not even a lot I'm
not even asking for Nintendo to operate
a lot but to me like okay they had keep
the hybrid you know but I do think
that they would do a lot better if they
tried to bring in a little bit more
third party you know what I'm saying
like so what I would like and you know
is to have like a dock that can make it
the the actual switch stronger that you
could play those third parties at home
like you could play all the other stuff
on the go but just the third party stuff
that they can't that they just simply
don't have enough power to play
um I I think they need to bring their
games into the 21st the 22nd century and
actually have voice
overs I think it's ridiculous that I'm
playing games that I'm still reading all
this dialogue years apart from each
other when
they when like the PS2 had it like it's
just like little things like that now
obviously they ain't gonna they're gonna
they're gonna go to their own horn and
it's just it's sad because it's working
for them yeah so it's like why would
they change anything just because we
don't like it don't mean that people
ain't buying their platform in the
dozens it's it's crazy it really is it's
insane the amount of yeah the amount of
sales that they get on this game it is
what it is on that you know I do feel
like
they need that one blockbuster title
that's like the Mario Odyssey more often
I feel like we get a lot of smaller
titles from them uh like Mario rabbits
uh Fire Emblem I would want those grand
Adventures like Zelda Mario Odyssey more
often and I also think that they they
need to
re-breathe life into older IPS like The
Icarus franchises like there's a lot of
ips they don't mess with well Kid Icarus
Kid Icarus president Nintendo what you
doing
oh um well
first thing I'm gonna do
I'm a John Cena the situation
um
Colin Phil on the phone
like yo what's up big homie
yo yeah I became CEO I said good mm-hmm
plans going accordingly
send over those papers
I'm selling the Microsoft day one oh you
you you're gonna be quiet
automatically we gonna be in the 21st
century
like no hardware for us
so check this out send all that game
pass put it straight over on the switch
we got we got thousands of games we
ready
um um the merger is gonna go through and
yeah we're gonna sell wholeheartedly to
y'all we're gonna make sure we get
around the FTC
Nintendo on Xbox for everyone
after one of their most successful and
generations
we're gonna take it to the next level
um
I'm gonna come out I'm gonna come out
with the fur coat uh you know they're
gonna be like you know how Reggie pizza
man came out my name is Reggie feeding
me and I'm here
okay and they take names well my name is
David Johnson and we for sale
we we selling the Microsoft day one oh
man
like seems like collusion I don't know
man I think we're gonna get the FTC on
that one I don't have a DMV go check out
Facebook real quick on second eight just
drop a trailer
um
reveal yeah yeah
look at it look it right it's like it
right it's like it right it's looking
right just wanna let y'all know what's
going on but um anyway yeah for me same
thing I'm kind of with attic are you
gonna sell no
I said it's attic I thought you said I
thought you were selling just like me
not being extra but um yeah look I'm
just gonna have them um a brief upgrade
at least to your wife if I please do
your Wi-Fi get Wi-Fi six and I will say
with King partner with Xbox on bringing
Game Pass and do a partnership with
Azure Cloud partner do a partnership
with Azure cloud like Sega did oh okay
put your joints over there and then let
Game Pass go through your old back door
whatever and then because they've been
playing around with the cloud technology
and that's it and with addict I'm like
yeah please get a party chat and look
whatever they doing is working they're
not gonna go too drastically that's just
what it is but that's you I'm just you
as the CEO yeah you as the owner
proprietor your world is law you Odin
over there yeah not not the Ragnarok
that's that's it
we we lit
we covered it how we lit we don't really
need it we in our own little lane that's
working and like people said they don't
care about the graphics with us right
right so my thing is this is expand the
base let's partner with them that gets
us out of making new hallway because
clearly we don't want to do that right
or make list they're doing a small
revision how they had the the pro I mean
the um the OLED right they had one with
the actual Wi-Fi in the chat in the box
and and that's it just do business so
you just want to be able to communicate
better yeah communicate better expand
your reach with a better Network and
Cloud okay and then and stick to the
format don't go you've literally got the
perfect format now just just stick with
it
you're taking a conservative uh measure
yeah but just just partner with
Microsoft as far as use them but what
are you giving Microsoft
as a business model I can hear you
knocking on my door talking about we
want to use but what are you giving what
are you sharing we giving you our
amazing user base that you need you
might need
sensitive but you like more screens we
gotta explain that is the most popular
screen pass over there yeah so what
you're saying is for for for us taking
you to the Future you want to give us
the path I mean last time I checked last
time I checked our numbers this morning
your installation this is true I think
you would like if you could take us on
the go and what if you give us a local
version
all right so high five Rush on on switch
screens and we might you know what we
would we include him in Smash we have we
have China you'll put you you'll put
them in Smiles I mean that sounds good
right now okay so now we cooking with
grease all right so
um what about we get a Mario game on
Xbox no no thank you
hello Phil hello I can't hear you you're
breaking up
Bowser out
oh so so when it comes to you really
giving up anything you you all hey you
one of these Instagram models yeah I
don't know what's going on with this
connection I didn't hear it all right I
heard game pack but I didn't hear Mario
I'm sorry sorry Phil the bad connection
I'll catch you later let me know when
the Azure contract's done mommy oh okay
so you just want the cash out yeah yeah
you ain't giving me nothing you just
want my cash app Money
yo your cough is crazy oh I see that I
see that move it off all right cool
attic this is you we are up topics
topics topics hold on you want me to get
these oh yeah
it's gonna get these out of the way
remember for 23 months Lord bronze
uh
uh why am I paying 400 pounds on two
controllers considering that I just
spent 12 hours straight
playing Halo with my daughter imagine
doing that with the full sense fees
and we got remedy live four pound 49
Pence Super Chat ain't about no gangster
list it's about keeping to those
commitments hashtag ghetto work deaths
I like that I like that there we got
Raider blade whatever for a year five
possible chat I never want to see
anything new from Xbox they should only
show up new IPS once it's ready to ship
stay quiet don't follow others Build
Your Mark sorry okay sorry
imagine if Microsoft just started Shadow
dropping everything they didn't do no
more marketing anymore
it could drop a game no doubt salute
Sloop then we got drive by Joe with the
five dollars
King in the Attic Fanboy voice oh man I
want to give a shout out to I have 11
000 followers on Twitter oh
so much so what I want you to do all
those guys that follow me on Twitter
just override these dudes please
just please I know we don't got as many
as Cog but we can fight Cog bad right
there we all got a band together
good to you then we have wow that we
have let's play with each other
monologuing always makes my joysticks
stick
yo I didn't even see what that came
through that's what you heard
[Music]
what if he live
D why y'all creating these scenarios
links in the description um play with
each other joystick for the paxy shirt
you can meet boo-boo
he drove 10 000.
laughs
yeah
what's the mean when the dude is like
wow
it's off I'm your biggest fan
if that go down that would be crazy
force is quick continue we got Malcolm W
two dollars in the chat Xbox Showcase in
July with us SF drop date of November
King we gotta admit Xbox games no matter
how good unless a flight Sim or Forza or
an Ori will suffer an Xbox tax on meta
sites Starfield no matter how good it is
getting six plus points less because of
Xbox
when it comes to that but that's just
fear-mongering at this point they can't
stop because when Microsoft was
publisher of the year
they did that with the same people
involved true that so again
just put out quality and you can
override I gotta say I know y'all was
saying that earlier that like that Hi-Fi
Russia people start trying to bomb it I
for the most part I saw like you kind of
unconditional love for the game yeah oh
no I was talking about the haters that's
who I oh okay okay
the five people that don't want to buy
Xbox to play
it's not Triple A man
I'm cracking two dollars which that high
five Rush might be double A but it is a
bang yes it is yes it is that's true
yeah it's a hashtag just one yes
y'all got a mess with me man damn
then we have done a taco remember for
when you're five dollars for chat
there's only three things that can
improve Nintendo one fix online two
improve switch Hardware every three to
four years three kill game freak and
pass Pokemon off oh this is all valid oh
hundred percent valid so I don't feel
like Pokemon needs to be passed off but
they they need to take more time on what
they're doing
then we have raka 23. five dollar Super
Chat yo Gamers need to stop being
entitled yeah that's wishful thinking so
many games to play games come out when
are they ready buy and play what you
like carry on okay appreciate that
appreciate that and we have I got jumped
a little bit hold on a second we have
Tyler cropsy
cropsy yeah cropsy five dollars which my
god king extra today with that jacket
when we going to see one of those on
Tuesday great show guys oh well the
reason why you don't see like the
jackets on Tuesday because my little
screen is mad small yeah
[Laughter]
that we have Dragonheart yo be five
dollar Super Chat don't be surprised if
old boy have the exclusive custom-made
IOP briefs with SOB on the back yeah
people want that song and can we play
with each other yeah
and it's a piece of life
okay
here we go yeah they loved it he got the
balloons on the side of that man with
the plethora of chloroform yeah y'all
seen the black phone
yeah
have you seen that King Ethan Hawke you
ain't trying to get me read the rest of
that stuff is about to wake up wearing
nothing but one of those shirts King is
required me to buy just to get it
yo listen I wake up in a basement
somewhere
stop stop is my um my into my reporter
my interviewer so he's not gonna be out
of my vision so the moment somebody put
something on his face they gonna have
something on their face
bro don't you do to y'all yo that's wow
with a long shirt
he gonna be what he starts to wear a
large he'll have a medium
eyebrows
that was wow
yeah we don't we sell cup koozies what I
don't know what's happening right now
okay well cup coolsis is all right is
this thing is asleep
come on Ty Moving On Moving On Moving
let's go
ah we got Dragonheart Yoshi it's a it's
a piece p-e-a-c-e with a little bit of
love and a whole lot of light yeah you
Wilding man you gotta stop y'all gotta
leave my man alone man y'all exciting
this person y'all better stop
[Laughter]
it
what if uh uh playing my joystick is
multiple people
I'm gonna be a victim to Buffalo Bill
he said quadruple
and put the lotion yo get the next one
you put the lotion there's a number one
big Dickens five dollars for chat wait
for the meeting will only hang just
above the man
this scenario was wow we gotta get to
these topics this is too much let's get
to these tacos actually solve it is you
it's your topic with uh Coalition it's
Coalition what's going on what's going
on Coalition man
yeah so shout out to Jeffy grub grub out
on his game mess Morning Show uh over
here you don't realize how many topics
we have to start straight up to Jeffy
half our shows about jazz and yeah
exactly so oh yeah but shout out to him
um so yeah on his game mess Morning Show
he indicated that uh that the Coalition
had uh basically transferred all of
their team to fully work on the next
gears game so gear six real soon right
and but that's what's interesting about
that is that a they had been somewhat
hit a little bit hit by the layoffs at
Microsoft right we don't I don't think
he actually mentioned the actual number
that they got sort of depleted by but
they were hit by that and in some way
shape or form that kind of could have
led to the cancellation of two smaller
projects that they had been working on
if you remember after gears five they
said they were going to take their time
to sort of get their bearings with
Unreal Engine 5 before they jumped in
full-fledged into gear six not that they
weren't working on it but it wasn't
going to be the next thing the
Assumption was it was going to be a
smaller game in Unreal Engine 5 so they
could sort of get their feet wet
um apparently there were two games being
two smaller games being worked on in the
interim here and those have been deleted
you know they haven't been deleted
I just I saw the word deleted I said it
they have been canceled uh in favor of
everybody just going to work on gear six
so
uh you know these guys they they helped
on Halo infinite they did The Matrix
awakens demo for um from PC Xbox but
they did that demo which is to this day
it's still amazing I still have it
downloaded and it's kind of crazy oh
yeah
um The Matrix demo so uh for me I was
kind of excited to see them work on
something else in between gears five and
uh High Busters and six so to see that
being canceled it just goes back to the
whole thing of like these like smaller
games sort of passion projects stuff
like that when it applies to the big
studios you would think they have the
leeway and The Leverage to just do it
right but when it comes to you know the
Coalition much like three four three
like the name says it all you're a gear
studio and at the end of the day gears
is gonna take precedence over anything
else and so they made the decision to
cancel these games
my question to you guys is what do you
guys think about it overall right but
for me it's one of those things like did
they cancel it just because of a
business decision or were the game's not
that great and then if that's the case
if the games weren't great like that
where it didn't it just made more sense
to cancel them then they had been
working on these games for quite some
time you know is this another situation
that we're looking at like you know we
always giving the Coalition sort of
process like they seem to run a tight
ship over there unlike other places the
Microsoft but if they were working on
two games
other places
there's one Studio three right three bro
stop acting like it's other Studio it's
one person point him out it's not one
person it's one person
my thing here is like yo if they cancel
this for anything other than we just
don't have the Manpower anymore
um instead of just shelving it for a
little bit outright cancel my thing is
like go
so that means the game was not good
enough how long have you been working on
this and how much time effort and
resources have you put into something
that you can't and I think that's a lot
of the problem we think about when we
think about Microsoft Studios and the
issues with with things being super
delayed and stuff like that entrench
management management not being being
able to get on the same page and things
like that so I I wonder if you guys
think any of that it could be a reason
for this and what do y'all think about
them just finally just saying okay we're
working on Gears that's the next thing
that's coming up
addict
um I actually look we could blame this
on management I guess we're the the
recent thing that's going on I could see
where people go through that but
Coalition regardless how you feel about
five you know the decision they had you
making the game I know a lot of people
didn't like that they've kind of did a
very good job of bringing gears to the
next level uh to the Next Generation
it's hard to retire a former cast and
bring it to another set of people and
people still care you know and I feel
like they did a good job you know they
did a better job than 343 you know they
still had Marcus in there but Marcus was
an afterthought Marcus was a character
to encourage the other people Marcus was
okay he wasn't the center right
three four three trying to do that lock
and failed horribly at it and it's just
like look like I think they're they're
going a good direction and until
Coalition shows me a reason to doubt
them it's like look then I'm assuming
you know whatever was decision was made
was the was the decision that was best
for the studio now if they're secretly
going stuff where they're canceling uh
canceling projects that's a different
conversation you know
ain't nobody gonna care if you're six
heads ain't nobody gonna care and to me
I didn't really care about whatever they
were working on I'll be right with you
like I really enjoyed gears five like as
a story aspect I I liked what I played
and this is for someone that didn't
really play Gears in the 360 era I
really like gears five and you know if I
get gear six quicker
so be it
that's just me as a selfish person you
know but what I will say is play games
like Hi-Fi Rush do make me want to see
these other Studios work on a smaller
title and I think that you know I think
they deserve that especially Coalition
we said on the show multiple times
Coalition literally put the Xbox one
generation on their back and carried it
up the mountain we got some inside bars
I don't know if you're cash out to the
legendary Lockhart I'm gonna check I
gotta break protocol he said uh so gears
5 came out 2019 against Pop in 2019
against five against tactics came out
2020. although we're pretty successful
just saying that's what I'm saying like
like people I don't know why you're
canceled I don't know yeah it's like the
same thing that when people talk about
you know Destiny oh Destiny's bad but
you have 500 hours in Destiny I know
people I know people that have days and
gear in the gears online and now they
say it's bad when you was playing
they might have made some balancing
updates that you didn't like because for
some reason the reason I don't touch
gears online is because I ain't going to
get I ain't going to get sideswiped by a
shotgun I didn't even know where the
hell it came from a second no no the the
wall thing like look they uh I I know
miles and Paris uh in Paris Lily are are
kind of like back and forth on what's
more important Halo or gears and I know
this is a little off topic but like I
gotta I gotta agree with Miles like I
think Halo Halo created the foundation
for for Microsoft but I honestly feel
like gears on the 360 error made it more
mainstream oh so we say again this is
the new New
Years
and I'm sorry like you know there is
from what I've seen because obviously
after when I was going to play Gears
four I wasn't going to go play those old
gears games on the 360 at the time
backwards compatibility was the thing so
I just looked up YouTube videos and a
lot of those those those cut scenes man
I can't imagine what it was like when
you were playing those back in the day
and they killing off main characters
like walking dead segments like it's
like you don't see that in Halo they
just don't kill people because it's a
game right when the Dom situation
happens yeah yeah for sure that was a
good one that was great so it's just
like sorry King no no no it's just it's
a different game putting people teeth on
the curb and stomping them in the back
of the head right I mean that's a
rebellious nature that was a lot more
edgier than you know uh other consoles
was going and that's the legendary
Cliffy B yeah that brought it to uh
which we may or may not have on the show
in the future yo
[Laughter]
all right continue
it's just that attic is right no doubt
no doubt oh that's all you have for it
for him no not for you
um oh okay give me the totality of the
question again so pretty much well yeah
it's off that the two Coalition games
the two Coalition games they got being
canceled yeah cancel then what do you
feel about them moving to gear six yeah
all right so Microsoft owns that studio
is in its entirety
any cancel project they don't go in
there and go delete in all the files and
everything right so it's like they're
doing a meeting like we're canceling
this project order it what's that order
delete the files delete everything get
me a coffee while you're at it that
stuff is putting you know in in cold
freezer to be Revisited at another time
what what y'all will hear in the news a
lot and you know I talked about it in
nausea with Attic in the background
you'll hear something called economic
downturn oh
that's code word for recession
all right we are in an economic downturn
so it's like that is that Spider-Man
artistic change
but this this stuff is you you see it
you want these games but economically
you can't afford these games not to hit
so okay they've you know stopped
production on this game and stop
production on that game put them in the
cold freeze double down on what we know
uh can actually make bread and we will
revisit these games at another time you
probably don't hear that uh in in words
uh as far as you know text and stuff
like that but you hear you know canceled
projects
those can't those cancel products will
be seen again when it's uh feasible
financially right now you cannot take
those outliers on games that haven't
been like let's say you know everybody's
looking at Hi-Fi Rush and look at how
far along that was we don't know when
that went in development we don't know
um at what point in time they said okay
definitely we're going to go forward
with this
we don't know what state those other
games are in that was canceled they
could have been halfway to half a high
five Rush uh standards they could be uh
not even a quarter away they could be
white boarded they could have been in
the the concept stages we have no idea
so I can't get an uproar over something
that they were working on the side
passion projects let's get to gear six
because we know we need to get that out
and that has to be in a Cadence that
makes sense for Microsoft yeah they were
doing one year Halo uh another year from
their Forza and another year gears yeah
we seem to have gotten out of that and
we have to get back to the to the gears
uh situation so let's get togethers
let's get gear six out the door let's
worry about uh probably gears tactic two
or something and then let's see these
projects that you have what I really
want and I hope that those projects
wasn't the Phoenix collection the market
Phoenix Legend I doubt that though that
that I doubt but that's that's where my
fear is right now now now if you're
saying yo the the Phoenix collection the
gears collection is being shelved no no
no I wanted that like I I wanted uh I
would Replay that if they touched all of
them I would replay I would play the
first three and actually replay four and
five they only did one part one I
remember when I was I was with Rod
Ferguson on that one when they showed us
the the one the first that's my first E3
but yeah it would be cool to get two
three and yeah I see I see a lot of
conversation about not like reinvent
like bringing these games forward do you
guys like think that they like the
industry is doing too much of older
games in terms of remakes you got you
know residue before uh Dead Space the
thing is if you want to reintroduce them
to a new generation that's not going to
play the old versions this is what you
got to do uh because I just think
there's a right and a wrong way you know
I feel like crime got the right way you
Capcom Square Enix and you know as long
as motives thing goes it goes correctly
I think those are the right ways and
those showed look we'll buy your gains
but we want worthy of those games we
don't want just oh we're going to touch
it up with a little pin
we want a full-blown reimagining and
built up from the ground up yeah that's
the thing when you look at um embracer
and all that they're doing right a lot
of their slate is supposed to be that
yeah and but they're doing it kind of
the wrong way where it's like it's not
when you start making the comparisons
like it's no comparison like I remember
what was the last one the Destroy All
Humans too whatever it was good but not
compared to none of this stuff and
imagine solve if they went out and they
made themselves the the studio that
remake stuff we do it right we do a
quality you would be having like these
other EA stuff they wouldn't make it
in-house to be like look embracer has
people that have been proven to do this
correctly let's let them do it yeah I
get it I mean I'll jump in there guys
got your balls on number
um look it's weird because I know where
you're going so I think for me I got to
be fair though like because these games
weren't officially announced yeah I
really can't get mad because it's like
all right for example scalebound got an
ounce then scale bound gets canceled
they deserve to smoke there's a lot of
stuff that gets canceled behind closed
doors exactly so I'm kind of on my
camera on like games and projects get
canceled every day all the time it's
just that Microsoft for whatever reason
it's so many things it always gets
zombies
you know I hate to say it but it's like
you don't hear about this from Sony like
I think the one time we heard about it
from Saudi was when shriya bled out the
report about big studio and I was like
oh they canceled days going too I was
like yo but we would have never heard
about that and that's because
they shouldn't have canceled it because
it was a successful game compared to
another game that got green lit and he
looked over but I think that's the same
thing here they looked over and saw how
foreign Rush get outside and um we got a
joint that got canceled our joint looked
better than that high five I don't even
think I know where you go but I don't
even think it's that look we got to give
Coalition Day flowers I'm with addict
Coalition holding it down since the Dark
Ages when Xbox one before they had when
it was just what five Studios or
whatever it was the small number of
Studios Coalition was always that gold
standard as far as graphical Fidelity
and like you said like taking a
franchise date I don't want to be
disrespectful three for three but they
were inherited something right right
that wasn't their baby initially you
know what I'm saying Cliffy being the
crew even Rod Ferguson goes on and
leaves right he goes to Blizzard and
they kept it moving they kept gears
going now you could say hey I didn't
like the multiplayer whatever but you
cannot you can't discount the whole
package and the quality of the game and
still very well received you know what
I'm saying so my thing is they've been
holding down and also we've heard
they've been helping out other Xbox game
studios get their games across the
Finish Line right because of their
technical prowess so I look at that now
where I'm with solved just selfishly
right is like okay we know like I guess
for me like I look at Coalition like
they had a graphical for dead like when
you're throwing that Hive Busters yeah I
was like this is what I want to see for
myself is that because of their lineage
to Epic it could be they they got that
Unreal Engine moving like when you look
at gears tactics the cutscene is pure
for dumb like okay so so one can say
that the only other people that know how
to use that engine better is epic
himself so my question to you right
because just this part yeah and I don't
mean to interrupt
it's just a focus bothering me I know
you I'm focused
y'all see you since you use Focus
continue stupid
um all right so do you think because I
hear there's a ton of problems with
Unreal Engine five right and they had to
cancel those products I mean those those
projects to get everybody galvanized and
getting this Unreal Engine 5 up to speed
it's not like Unreal Engine four I know
a lot of these armored developers think
it's a button press right we just
magically transferred over and
everything is shiny and new
um but do you think it's like getting
everybody on one page Hey listen
everybody we need to focus on this right
here because this project is taking a
little bit longer because of the
learning curve on Unreal Engine 5. what
I think is what happened is probably
they had a plan we're gonna do these
smaller little games get activated
Unreal Engine five then man blast off
into gears six the vibe I'm getting
especially in Junction shot to grab his
report is that
what's the Matrix demo they did people
forget they did The Matrix demo yeah
that Matrix demo was fire I don't know
if y'all tried it it's crazy it's crazy
so that was them playing around Unreal
Engine founding we got to be real the
layoffs yeah the financials that affects
that effects so maybe they go look we
had this big robust plan for you to do a
whole bunch of stuff but now you guys
seem comfortable and they say hey we
don't we're comfortable after the demo
all hands on deck to gear six the only
thing where I agree would solve is
selfishly I would love to see what
Coalition could do free of Gears just to
show because I think they are the
hashtag just one Studio I think that
they had them dudes that you put them on
anything like the they they know how to
get to the metal to me when I look at a
coalition game graphically they're
getting to the metal I tell people all
the time but at the beginning of the
series X launch when people are like yo
I'm not seeing the flops I'm like did
you play high Busters though yeah don't
have buses and tell me
see it could an argument could be made
like post-rod right post Rod you got to
worry because Rod was the closure Rod is
the one that keeps everything in check
Hive Busters is the argument against it
yeah yeah it is
how dope is it when this ABK deal goes
down we get robbed back yeah
listen Rod is the closest Rob will get
you again Rod is exactly what king loves
he makes sure you get your games on that
timeline of course that deadline with
high quality his whole MO is that so
like is huge the only mistake Rod almost
made was was Kansas was wanting to
cancel a fortnight
remember on on the day that we was
camping out out there
yeah so one of us I'm not gonna throw
the Lord on the bus one of us said oh I
love your games
he said really which one
and he put the gun put the gun on like
yeah which one yeah oh boy
[Laughter]
it wasn't me
I wasn't there
500 people
no security shout out to run I was there
when the gears one remake nobody knew
about it 4K 60 Xbox One demoed in the
building next to Raw we rocking it yeah
yeah that was a beautiful thing but yeah
salute look at them and then I was gonna
finish I'm saying I agree with you I
thought them and Ninja Theory have the
best potential for hashtag he was my
what uh with PlayStation's type of games
that they make like yeah
now I got to put it into that right now
they're going after me huh no no I thank
you for clearing that up because the
child was coming after me first of all
only two people on this panel was there
right but it was a Lord that y'all don't
see on this show correct well you have
to be specific you know what it is
because you said Lord so they
automatically assume this is the Lord
you gotta say you had to say like an
affiliate yeah
so it's just like Ninja Theory and
Coalition I feel like
they're the ones that's going to make
that that PlayStation template game and
as long as you keep them on Gears
they'll never find that that creative
muscle shout out yeah no doubt shout out
to Bosley that's one of our IOP West
Coast Lords you know what I'm saying
again we got Lords that's not doing
podcasts is that do a podcasting there's
some lawyers that don't care about video
games so you better not run up see and
Bone slave is our Snapchat
be respectful in the comments cause
dudes don't
lose ain't about
how much achievement you got if you
disrespectful to us
we ain't gonna do those that we're gonna
keep it peaceful we're gonna keep it
peaceful we're gonna move it but yeah
that's what I got uh great topics of um
I did want to throw in hold on we had
that then we had to um no no I'm bugging
we had the other that's the next topic
so we go you want to give you some
checks yeah we're down a second oh yeah
Dragon heart yo remember four when
you're five dollars hashtag peace love
life from me to you all y'all give us
entertainment is only right we provided
back tape
it's questionable whether that's
Entertainment or not right
that shirt no no one thing I will say is
we we like 20 away from 25 of our goals
yeah I will say that beautiful thank you
I'm looking at the goals going I'm like
wow
like we almost got to the to the to the
25 25 already no that is impressive all
of this helps us as we get the packs
Hotel house trips all of this man to
give y'all the content that we love to
give you you're gonna really like what
happens at paxto I'm telling you now oh
for sure for sure you're gonna really
like it we we're crafting it in a way
that if we get approval for this one
thing it's we're going to change the
game oh no question yeah that's the way
that is like is going to change and
You're Gonna Wanna Be at every show
because this is focused man that fault
bro you on the Focus right now I really
like this
yo I'm not even a thing in front like
because yo when God called me this
morning I was feeling beat and broken
hey I'm not gonna lie but then I took
this phone
body links in the description Advance
gg.com but you was called Island check
out get your discount all I drink is
focused during the show that's it yeah
why he raises super chats I'll share the
uh oh yeah here we go nice and we got a
flame member for two years five dollars
of chat good afternoon IOP I say let
Coalition make what they want and let
343 be a support studio so they can feel
like they're doing something again wink
wow
wow that's disrespectful stop it flick
yeah we got clutch manual one five
dollars Which hat Tango should
collaborate with Ariel night for a
hip-hop sequel or that'd be kind of
crazy I always think about a hip-hop
game like that yeah man we got a project
on the phone yeah yeah project Shaolin
yes we do then we have Mr two
opinionated five dollar Super Chat I
worry about franchise fatigue with gears
and Halo there's only so much you can do
with IP I'm glad Naughty Dog decided to
let Uncharted rest I mean it's one thing
that is franchise fatigue it's fatigue
for the team Uncharted ain't going
anywhere just Naughty Dog isn't making
it anymore they're gonna pass it off to
somebody else and I think that's that's
what happens
exactly which logo just the logo that we
have playing during Super Shots oh I did
I did just keep knocking it off okay
okay yeah I noticed that I did that we
good stuff yeah we got Gerald Mack 20
Super Chat here goes that 20 you need to
reach that 25 I'm in the building
salute the Lords wait wait OG pulling up
taxis they're gonna be there you got the
shirt with Gerald Mack oh that'll be
dope they see Joe Matt yo he always pull
up brother that's what's up Raymond
stick together yeah you already know
Boston gonna be lit okay it depends on
how late it's gonna be gonna see a fur
coat they'd be cold it might be warmer
it might be freezing
and it is uh your topic sir you want me
to set you up
turtle and Dragon Age and Titanfall
games yeah you can say yeah so shout out
to um again looks like grub is in the
mix this week bro is it a mix man so
Titanfall Titanfall game cancel this
week was reportedly a campaign in Apex
Legend it's exclaimed that the
unannounced experience would have had
players teaming up with Apex characters
and then um yeah according to grubby
grub that um he said 50 people have been
working on it at on Titanfall Legends at
respawn these EA Studio was announced at
20 uh July 2021 it was developing a new
single player Adventure game set in a
unique universe and it was supposed to
be a Titanfall feeling project the
freedom um and inside of it's hugely
popular you know Apex Legend and then it
says Titanfall Legends was not Titanfall
3 because a lot of people's minds I
think tiger 43 was going to be a new
Standalone game with a single player
campaign and multiplayer and they could
just never do that again after Apex
Legends changed the calculus of all
those things so now they're talking
talking about Titanfall ledge was
supposed to be a slot as a part of that
where it would have a single player
campaign inside the platform the same
way like Call of Duty has you know
Modern Warfare war zone and all that
other stuff so yeah abilities and
they're supposed to have BT was
allegedly supposed to be there from the
titanforce wow um two-story players with
players Apex Legend character blisk and
navigate the world with an upgraded BT
it is claimed so attic what is your
feelings on this alleged cancellation
uh if EA cancels that I'm so
disappointed in them like it's you know
they built these characters up in Apex
Legends and a lot of them really love
these characters in Apex Legends it it's
just like
do you you do a good job with like dead
space you do a good job of like the Jedi
Survivor Jedi fall in order and it's
just like man I feel like you know you
would have opened up this this world
with respawn and Titanfall let them you
know Branch out explain certain
characters I think you could have
resulted in a better Titanfall 3
whenever they do get to it because I
think they're definitely going to make a
Titanfall three it's just are we gonna
be alive when it happens I don't know
like you know it's it's sad man because
there's so many good characters and and
Apex Legends and Apex Legends and
Titanfall was in the same universe so
it's just like it's disappointing
because we want a
a Titanfall so bad imagine the hit if
they would have because apparently in
the rumor the the antagonist from two
was supposed to come back to life or
something like that I don't know you
were supposed to play as one of the
characters from Apex Legends and the
rest was supposed to be in the game or a
few of them I don't know if all there's
a lot of people in Apex Legends at this
point it's just it's just disappointing
like even if they didn't do it I would
like a like a single player of like
imagine playing the the game
as an apex Legend match like it's just
like one thing you don't want to say
like you dropped on this map and the
whole game is about you going through
this this this
match
and every like you you come across the
bosses as actual people like I think it
would have been lit there's a lot of
things they could have did in this game
to make a good sadly we will never see
it you know hopefully Jeff grub will
leak more
but you know I hope that you know maybe
they didn't do this because they're
actually going to give us Titanfall so
it's hard to tell
solve what are your thoughts on this
Beauty yeah okay I didn't know you went
yeah shout out to the police there's oh
people yeah it got a little warmer today
and people wilding out outside
police police on patrol so
um yeah man I can get the same with the
with the Coalition stuff anytime I hear
something like this especially Titanfall
Titanfall we got details on this one
right details we didn't know about what
college
yeah imagine if they would have did like
the origins of like a very popular
character from Apex Legends like
yeah like that oh it's there's a there's
a very I can't remember his name chat I
know you're going correct and that's
perfectly fine I love it all right he he
he's like very cocky in Apex Legends I
can't remember his name Mirage that's
his name Mirage and he he's like he
always he he loves himself
it would have been nice to have a game
of his origins of why he has that
confidence why he feels like he he's
everyone's icon like it'll be lit yeah
yeah
and that's the thing right to me first
of all the fact that it it has to be
built in Apex because of what they've
done to get that whole IP bothers me a
little bit talk about it because I'm
gonna tell you right now like you know
all right the original Titanfall was an
XBox One exclusive and obviously Xbox
One did not take off the way PlayStation
did so you know the argument is or it
was stranded on there right and it was
only multiplayer so it limited the
appeal somewhat but I loved it I think
it did great there I loved it so when to
see the sequel come out with a single
player campaign someone got the Dominus
hoodie salute salute anonymous
anonymous let's go so to see the second
one come up with a campaign be
everywhere and then to have them just
cannibalize themselves by releasing it
so close to Battlefield for no reason it
just like to me they've always put that
franchise at a disadvantage for no
reason whatsoever because like second
game is objectively one of the best for
SPF games ever period objectively This
is not capping this is not that game is
amazing that single player campaign is
amazing the multiplayer is amazing like
so to see it have to be attached to Apex
I'm a little I'm hating a little bit
right yeah I don't want to wait till
it's my turn right if you could even you
could even give it Like An Origin
character that hated the program hated
the machine
he refuses to use them it's just it's
sad man it's like I don't understand
what EA thinking they they green light
like a dead space remake but they won't
give an original Ip in the TitanFall
Universe like I love the remake of Dead
Space it's cool but it's just like
people would have lost their minds
[Applause]
the thing is is I don't I think people
would lose their mind because if it's
respawn let me put it that response okay
any more hours
making it they showed us Apex Legends
Titanfall and they showed us Jedi
following order and Survivor there's no
way people ain't hyping this game oh man
okay okay I gotta hit so I understand
all right let me real quick understand
so I understand they're thinking about
well we're gonna do it we're gonna do it
as part of Apex because Apex is is is
the popular franchise right I get it so
I I really don't understand it's Apex
still making money hand over fists I
understand respawns working on Jetta
Survivor it might be working on some
other stuff as well I get it
just do it hey it's one of those things
I can just do it just sent itself look
at the center he said that Titanfall
Legends was was not Titanfall 3 because
in a lot of people's minds EA I think
type 4-3 was going to be a new
Standalone game with single player
campaign and a multiplayer but this the
key part and they could just never do
that again after Apex Legend changed the
calculus on all things
any service based game any service based
game the calculus changes right all of a
sudden you put out a free-to-play game
that's making money hand over fist right
day in and day out so they're saying
because of that
I understand that from an optic
standpoint it's probably way more
beneficial for them to find it to keep
putting money uh into something like
that because they can actually make
money off of it I don't think you're
going to aim for a hundred percent of
the people playing Xbox Legends but I do
think there's gonna be a lot of people
that love these characters that are
willing to try it and you got to single
player heads playing it and it's going
to be a multi-plat I I just I find it
hard to believe this game would be
successful I mean um my father's order
was successful I agree because that's
the thing it's just all of a sudden so
what all in order
it's not I I understand what kings
called I was there
basically they said um they're talking
about the powers they said the thinking
there was that more people have played
Apex Legends than have even heard of
Titanfall so they were really going to
lead into that no you're right I
understand where you're going song he
said it's their fault full okay
at that point not the people's fault if
more people's played Apex Legends and
those characters are beloved by all
these people why would a game what those
characters not do well I hear that okay
here we go you ready you ready I'm just
saying your logic is sound sir
you have a franchise where every
characters be loved
and let's just put it out there or just
let them play Apex Legends to play these
beloved characters that's there you know
you're talking about Jedi falling order
that's a one-off that's a Star Wars
franchise you have the Star Wars people
that's gonna buy it some people don't
even open it because they just want to
be part of the Star Wars I feel you but
there's been plenty of Star Wars games
that didn't that well because they just
weren't good games yes it's gonna take
you everywhere Star Wars Battlefront 2
with all the issues it had still did
well wow there's there's clearly why
obviously because they turned it around
why because the gameplay was good and I
can be Darth Vader and I can be Luke
Skywalker I'm sorry Star Wars hey you're
not a Star Wars head so Star Wars heads
is gonna go with Star Wars heads want to
be okay now you can have crappy games in
series
they just won't sell but I believe they
would sell more than a regular game that
you put out with an average character
from Apex right so you got to look at it
as a as a business
all right this is business man this
ain't oh what your dreams is I would
like to have a character thrown in the
world and you can have this as a match
and the boss is an actual character bro
that sounds nice but they not doing that
nobody's taking we're in an economic
downturn it's not like this Fortnight
some stuff is Gonna Get You Know thrown
to the Wayside as much as Titanfall was
just Dope Game yeah first one was dope
second one was even better it didn't get
the reach wow and a dope game will get
reached right if it's so dope how come
nobody heard it okay
let me let me push back on that yeah why
is the anime why did the anime makers of
my hero put my hero in fortnite King
is the anime not dope the anime is out
right now that's why because they wanted
people to play that game and see it it's
like yo where'd this character come from
it's the anime dope why what why are
they putting IPS in fortnite
strategically around when the game
actually comes out when the movie
actually but anime dope so games ain't
dope I'm just saying this you keep don't
attach it to fortnite don't don't attack
people do the same thing they put it in
there to get consistent looks on that
character to help sell the movie all
right you think they push stuff like
Spider-Man to come out around the game
in hand and cross market and cross
perform so why can't you take that same
mentality in in Titanfall in this type
of whole universe
Legend and you putting it up there with
fortnite
you're gonna bring it across the street
to the 800 pound gorilla you're gonna
take that chimpanzee back
continue
I'm looking at the uh the days there is
there is awesome I was playing that game
okay on all platforms there's 10 million
daily users on apex Legends
are those single player Gamers that one
you think those 10 million gonna come
over play you'll see
all right what about what about okay
what about in the way they were thinking
because to your point like even though I
it hurts to say this
um to your point there is a huge
contingent as popular as Apex is that
never even heard attack before don't
even know what type of is or don't care
what that is right but what about to you
to what Atticus said is in the sense
like they call Apex Legends right and
they know Apex right and now this is
like the bridge the cap the generations
of the old heads and the new the young
youngins right and you have that mold
like how Warzone has where you go you
open the Call of Duty Suite you can do
Call of Duty or you could do war zone
you don't okay
all right let me hear Let me see if this
is what you're saying right I'm just
talking about what they would say this
is what they wanted to do
merge this dead franchise oh God merge
the dead franchise with a living Beating
Heart right right this dead body right
we're gonna put a live heart in it yeah
it's an option right we're gonna take
all right so we're gonna take the live
harder Apex we hope that the 10 000 to
10 million votes decide is gonna charge
this body exact location
it's expansion what if that dead body
kill the heart
all right yo ain't nobody out here I
ain't hearing nobody calling for no
Titanfall nothing wow dudes is out here
yo you know cause Titanfall go play it
then get those numbers back up this
isn't Titanfall though this is a game in
the TitanFall universe
that is true all right so listen
obviously they have the metrics there
right and they didn't want to risk the
risk it for the biscuit they didn't want
to yeah they looked over and said you
know what that's nice just not right now
maybe later we'll come back to it maybe
once we finish oh BGA the mix cat cake
people definitely want to fight
song you
good
you not 10 million people
as much as I love you it's a thing
though I would agree with you the other
two I don't want it and I don't want
what you talking about I would agree
with you if I felt like they didn't
build up the Apex Legend Universe the
way they did There's A Story characters
know each other they have built up this
universe where it could easily Branch
out to a single player make indie games
of it
oh my God
you know what just take little passion
projects
bro this was an XBox exclusive at one
point you got the statue bro yeah listen
right right yeah you got the headset bro
I was the fool me and a couple of other
people just don't try like that game was
not popping do not do that it was
popping for its time
let's Let It Go okay it's not it was it
was iconic for its moment right now if
you want to do this let's say this why
don't you do an apex why don't you do a
cross promotion this way have a Titan
for a week where at Apex you can call
down a Titan they did that didn't they I
don't know because I wasn't playing I
think they did something similar to that
you got Kings speak on the universe he
has absolutely no knowledge he's not
crazy and if it was popular I would have
been there
you played war zone it's one of the most
popular games
seriously they tried it and it did work
I'm sorry again it makes no honestly it
that that whole argument about the
calculus didn't work out I don't see it
I just don't see it I I don't see the
math there because the math I mean they
did but they said no they said I'm not
gonna risk my good heart putting it in
his weak body
I can't stand on his own I got kidney
problems
yo listen let's just remember how it
used to be yeah
they gimped it to themselves
that's what makes me mad like if you
didn't give it yourself and it just you
put it out in the wild and then I was
feeling it bro they literally hurt
themselves
but the thing is I'm with you right and
I say yeah but I'm not putting a poll in
the chat
I'm not feeling a franchise just to
please you guys listen I hear what you
saying on the metrics the numbers I get
it pure business I get it because it's
one of the most popular multiplayer
games you're saying it with tank Apex
that's what you're trying to say like
Apex is out of here but the thing is
like he is completely omitting the fact
that this is the most self-inflicted
reason why Titanfall 2 did not do as big
as it should have you literally sandwich
it between your own game in Battlefield
and Call of Duty to say go out there and
survive like the release date Cadence
that they put Titanfall 2 it was one of
the dumbest things in the history of
gaming so all I'm saying is I'm with the
chat and my brothers that if you give
Titanfall 3 a proper launch and release
window and Let It Rock it can survive
now I'm with you King that Apex is the
wave and imma be 100 I've never said
nothing like this before
that Apex Legends is successful
like it burns
I hate that Apex Legends is a successful
I'm gonna be cognated today look I get
it it is amazing game I played it
respawn whenever you touch his gold I
just hate that your perfect streak
continued on apex Legends because I I
wouldn't mind if it was Apex babies I
love y'all but I wouldn't mind if it
went away and I gotta tell you for it I
know that's for you that's for you I get
it but in a world because
of how successful attic game is I'm
never gonna get myself and that's my
ball is my soul so it's like what are we
here look I I ain't no disrespect you
know what I'm saying it's just that my
thing is they never let the baby get
born right like they put the baby in
hostile conditions yeah like bro what
did you expect and now you're like oh we
know the sentence oh we don't know you
know the Matrix the calculus we could
never put it out now in Titanfall like
bro so the only thing I will say that
this one does bother me because even
though I'm not getting my Titanfall
three
you could have bridged the gap between
both angering Factory because you got
added apexful week in there no listen
listen and then and then you got the
title for a whole demographic yeah
we're doing that for fortnite
because you could have had the youngins
playing Apex talk about yo stay apart
for Titanfall so boom drop on the map
and they're like oh what's this and now
you build awareness of this great thing
that you made that you abandoned and
that's what you could have bridged it
you know what they said that's all we
care we can't we can't have two live
Services that's it it could only be one
this is my land
war zone proves you could do it Warzone
proved you can do it why because they
got it as a separate mode you could play
the Battle Royale you could do you know
main things Call of Duty how you wanna
do it all right yeah
okay let's say there we're going to meet
you halfway we're going to make the
single player revolve around all the
Apex Legends character and the
multiplayer is going to be your
Titanfall style multiplayer oh it might
upset
they ain't gonna like that they changed
no multiplayer I think you Gotta Have
Nothing single players single player is
going to be the single player they wanna
but the multiplayer of the game is going
to be the TitanFall style multi hell no
but the multiplayered as willing
unfortunately
but Nothing's Gonna Change with apex
apex is going to keep going just like
Apex always has one oh so you're gonna
have a separate Apex you're gonna have a
separate Titan for a multiplayer and
then you have a separate single player
campaign oh my God never mind
talking about a new game it's about a
new Titanfall game no no I'm talking
about the game that they wanted to make
okay the one that is taking place in the
TitanFall Universe it's not Titanfall
it's just with the character correct
correct but they give you the
multiplayer of Titanfall attached to it
a new modern Milwaukee layer okay
um
because they are some Pilots That's in
the Apex right so uh some Pilots they
give you them characters for new pilots
they they really broaden what they
learned from uh respawn that's what I'm
saying it's like look like both could
win they still give you a single player
on Call of Duty Noe that war zone is
raining at 80 of the money
so so question is this do we know if it
was something that was going to be built
inside of Apex yeah or was it going to
be Apex adjacent and it just make it
known it's an apex game
Titanfall I know this is great title
letters will be a single player campaign
inside of this platform on top of the
Apex spot in the same way Call of Duty
Works where you can get Modern Warfare 2
and Warzone in the same in the same
package yeah okay so just like the
convoluted thing I just said that I
couldn't find my Call of Duty it was at
the bottom in the corner like some old
uh you know Caster side you know
campaign yeah that's what they want
that's all I got but um yeah it's just
interesting to see what happened
hopefully this doesn't mean ten four
threes no this is in the bushes yeah so
hopefully we'll see what's going on
anyway
because unfocused
foreign
[Music]
verified B
okay cool that we have Joe back uh
remember for two years five dollars to
be chat not coming from that far east
I'll definitely catch you at E3
see you out there in the west side then
we got spark go 17.5 pounds Super Chat
you were basically asking EA to put Cod
to put Cod advertising Budget on
Titanfall when the first one had mid
performance that's crazy though
that got othered by the rest of gaming
like you know come on come on dude spawn
go 17 two props for chat BG average
Gamers don't give a damn about
Titanfalls
let's go that's life
I mean it might be one of those Echo
Chambers maybe you don't know like maybe
maybe yeah they got the number yeah yeah
all right I mean I guess we could agree
though that like that's for a game that
good to just be like ah nah we don't
care like that's crazy crazy
real quick we did forget the damn bonus
topic which was uh Dragon Age Dre dread
wolf you ready to play leaked rumors is
out
um addict you seem very passionate um
where you at with it for what you've
seen
oh look I'm not gonna jump to
conclusions what I look like didn't look
like the drag anges that I've played
um but you know hopefully
they have like here's the thing like
they people don't like the action pace
of it
they've been kind of mass affecting that
that's that the the the speed of the
game for you for the past couple
installments so it's like you know if
the can uh the companions are there the
story lines are there the love interests
are there the story in general is there
then it's like look like oh
whoop-dee-doo you know it's just the
game looks good I think that's all that
really matters because at these days
like that old style RPG thing just don't
work out anymore and you know as much as
I love those type of games a lot of
people don't and you know one could say
that we have too many Stu Studios trying
to appeal to a casual and forget about
their core audience and then once the
game comes out they've missed everyone
uh hopefully that don't work out for
them but if it don't we'll be we'll tell
you no doubt game inspired so far
heavily inspired by 2018 God of War
cinematic hacking slash more Focus enemy
animations pirate counters sword and
shield they said party but like it was
party command attacks that you bring
them in but not directly like the way
they all went kind of like uh Guardians
yeah like audience orb soft quick what's
your thoughts on the the reported leak
uh beta leaks or whatever of dragon I
mean you can't look you know anything
coming out of BioWare is going to be
under la freaking scrutiny and at the
end of the day if the team they have
there is not built to make those type of
RPGs anymore in that way
um then yeah man like I I can see them
trying to flip it on its head and we saw
we saw with Dragon Age 2 uh that people
a lot of people were not super happy
with the direction that it took so to go
to a more action-y is is kind of a
little bit of a risk and it's supposed
to going back to something classic but
again if that's what they're built for
that's what they're built for what I saw
was seem very early it seemed choppy
whatever but the idea that you have this
super action-based combat with parrying
and stuff like that with RPG elements
that are hopefully deeper than a God of
War that's intriguing to me right and
like addict said if you could still do
all like the upgrades of the party and
stuff like that and the stories there I
again I I'm mad at people trying to do
different things so I'm I'm down for it
I'm not going to judge it yet um we'll
see I've always felt like and I don't
know how you feel called like Dragon
age's core Foundation is the World
building the character development
that's the core foundation and as long
as they get that right and make that but
here's the thing they got to make that
combat hit right it can't be generic
it's got to feel good no I'm with you
I'm with you um I I don't know if King
cares about leaks and beta yeah I do oh
cool 98 dudes just a lot of stuff
that's what NBA dudes do you can't say
nothing but wait
but wait here's more anyway
um
you saw that right yeah in the store
um get the store right now hit the link
it's yo the game looks good okay I like
that I love the Aesthetics of the game I
can't wait to play the game I hope the
RPG elements is as deep as it was before
if not deeper uh with the ability to run
around like Final Fantasy uh seven
remake or Final Fantasy uh the last one
I played with them in the cars and stuff
like that
uh I'm not going to judge it based on
some leaks of some unfinished stuff Sam
but is it a game that I'm looking
forward to hell yeah and it's a game I
love RPGs so it's a game that I'm gonna
you know dig deep into and play it and I
love you know um Western RPGs mainly
because they they dig into a little bit
of minutia that I like a little bit more
you know so yeah it's gonna be fun yeah
I pretty much agree with pretty much all
y'all I mean um it's a beta I'm not
gonna go too crazy I know my boy bad
he's a little scared you know about the
the core concerning obviously you know
what I'm saying but if they're going for
the God of War 2018 you feel as far as
combat you know I'm willing to give it a
shot I think Dragon's Age Inquisition I
ended it that's why I really love the
game and the story of The Dread wolf is
something I'm very interested in so look
Gog what's up I'll ask you a question
yes sir
why do everybody want to attach their
face to to God of War it's funny you say
that perfect transition into the next
topic let's do that so um it's great I
know before we before we slide what's
going and we're there we already shut
the door
let's get into it why don't why wouldn't
they attach it to an RPG that is
successful that does Action RPG things
um uh action game right you know and
what I saw wasn't representative of God
of War at all no I get where you going
right so why is people keep attaching it
because what I think
it's to attach it to a Sony game in
order to pull the Sony guys over because
they know they're gullible right so you
say oh you know it's like that and you
know the Sony dude's like it's like God
of War I'll buy it
I'm just saying no I get it listen In
fairness all we know about is the combat
scene we don't know if the I mean I get
you know to the extent of it but they
could have modeled remember they didn't
look like that at all right it didn't
look like it looked like anything
is they only focus on like the
hand-to-hand call yeah we didn't see
like they don't focus on like the Mage
building with the magic and kind of like
really look at every aspect and not just
one two clips or trying to formulate
like this whole yeah I'm waiting till
the whole thing come out yeah like my
thing is it still could probably have
all the RPG elements the the choice the
decisions the Mass Effect likes if they
have that I'm fine you can have
everything God award don't yeah
I'm Gonna Keep it a buck I'm at the
point in my life I don't know if y'all
agree but what's up I can't like like a
hardcore RPG going through menus and
stuff like I don't have the time so if
they if they actionify more RPGs I ain't
really mad I'm about to throw Persona 5
on my place I'm waiting for my son to go
home so because I looked at I was like
you know what that's something I haven't
gotten into and that's a go through the
menus type of thing so look that was
it's early but Drew both leaks are out
on these streets
yeah let's just go let's just go because
I gotta go no no let's go oh yeah this
is where this is where I reside this is
where you use that so let's talk about
it let's hold on hold on so y'all can
see that I'm putting the focus in a
better cup hold on hold on because you
you know we're gonna get to the stop
section but um and if we pull up with
this yeah
it talk to you too didn't talk to you
exactly don't know so let's talk about
these uh these numbers may God of War
Ragnarok drives
9.6 billion in the quarter for
PlayStation Sony almost sold double the
amount of PlayStation 5 units as the
same quarter in the previous year some
highlights shout out to games
industry.biz for the um third quarter
the segment they saw that sales uh saw
53 compared to the previous year which
it attributed to increased hardware and
first party sales with God of War
Ragnarok have it launched within that
period Sony Santa Monica titles sold 11
million units since launch the games uh
segments operating income was up 25 as
well those uh solely noted increasing
costs associated with the acquisition of
Bundy and Bungie excuse me Bundy another
thing that they are I want to shot the
video games Chronicle PlayStation 5
enjoys its best sales quarter yet
reaching 32 million shipped and
Christmas console sales were up 83 year
on Year boasted by the broad
availability in stores and yeah they say
that that's the what you call it um
supply issues be over so I also said
that last month that it sold 30 million
PlayStation 5 units to Consumers which
means about uh 2.5 2.1 could remain in
the channel based on today's shipped
figures so they're seeing a lot of
growth you know even our monthly active
users are up they talked about that
um
and yeah it just seems to be a great
time for them so I just want to know
wait a second you said the monthly
active users is up uh what what about
the the PlayStation Plus subscribers The
subscribers are down by one million
users yeah however despite by 1 million
by one million because they but they
sold a lot but yeah the people ain't
subscribing to their service okay but
they the revenue which includes the
revenue that they made is uh okay so the
revenue is up because they keep trying
to say
yeah okay so the revenue is up is that
because they raised the price on the
console I mean they made more money you
know so so then they said um yeah they
talk about the active users we talked
about that into Kingsport I think they
did mention about the active users
there's still a percentage of
PlayStation 4 on on the monthly after
users as far as that served yeah but
overall you know this is tremendous news
for Sony so I wanted to get start with
uh addict the numbers guy okay it's all
about sales and numbers which field to
me yeah I know
what purposely he said I care about what
yeah you know how you always all about
the numbers King I think he wants you to
talk no but you want me to talk no king
is we're not ready there let's get
together you're not ready it's like look
like it it's impressive uh God of War uh
we knew this was gonna sell well uh we
always knew I I am curious to see how
many of those was that bundled oh no
debunked already by Benji sales bungee
sales already ready for y'all he said
for those trying to say it was the bug
news it is not the case so yeah we we
already had it at
so I'm curious they didn't sell a bundle
of God of War in it no I'll get you I'll
get you exactly that was in every
picture I seen
literally got in front of that for
people saying that it was just bundles
on that situation no I'm not saying it's
just bundles I'm saying that did
contribute to its numbers I'm gonna get
the tweet I should have had it ready but
you continue to keep talking keep
talking I mean here's is the thing okay
here we go legitimately LM laughing at
people saying this is primarily driven
by bundles spoiler alert it's not the
majority of all Ragnarok copies sold
have been Standalone but to your point
bundles definitely didn't hurt though
that's what he said I mean he said
majority so far we know the majority is
8 million and they sold a couple million
off of bundles like that it is what it
is I'm not saying that the bundles is
the sole reason it's so well
I'm saying it definitely added a little
not a little a little bit
and now here's the thing though but we
can't like he said really can't over
emphasize how insane the numbers are 11
million sold in less than three months
for a console exclusive
um
big bro that's big yeah I think that's
the first between two consoles
but it's impressive that's not
far-fetched though I mean basically the
other day like the God of War
I I don't I don't
I don't
what's what I'm looking for it's I
completely understand no I know I
believe it because here's the thing like
I'm hard on games I've been my entire
life and I suggest you go by by God of
War I didn't see too many people say not
to buy God of War Ragnarok so it
deserves the money deserves the the
success it's just all I'm saying is you
know that little cushion that I got from
bundles was there and you know sure
probably only equal to maybe a million
or two uh maybe a little bit more than
that I probably wouldn't say anything
more than three uh because they sold a
lot of those bundles during Black Friday
almost everything was bonded with God of
War Ragnarok so it's just it's good I
I'm enjoying it because I I've always
been a huge adamant on person if you
make good games you get rewarded they
made a good game they got rewarded uh
but I I I'm willing to say uh you know
this this
this game makes me think they're gonna
be a a PlayStation 6 man oh you do say
it
they think that PlayStation ecosystem is
healthy right now oh my God yeah there's
no reason not to do it but I heard that
I heard you ready for it
no no no we got to go around the room
first
it's like I said the the game is good it
deserves the sales you know uh when we
were talking about Hi-Fi rush it sold
really well on Steam in the PlayStation
and look you made good games people show
up that's just how it is from all the
time it doesn't matter what you you make
a good game not sure there's exceptions
that fall through the crack and I hate
that for them but for the majority of
the time if you make good games people
will show up and on this particular
moment they made a game that uh that
everyone loved and people showed up
I won't be a little petty um what type
of style of game is this
yeah but with people people people like
good games in general people like uh
people like you know you look at games
like like
Titanfall right now
shut up shut up
it's not your turn you look at games
like The Witcher does very well Fallout
4 sold really well like like game game
good game sell regardless person that's
right what viewership yeah it's crazy
they sell Regal wow
anyways PlayStation 5 sales just to put
it to you this way Fallout 4 sure it's
been out a lot longer it's been out
three years longer
The Fallout 4 edition has sold 13
million and the regular Fallout so uh
more than that so it's like look at the
end of the day games are going to sell
very well if they're good it doesn't
matter now I do agree with with Cog you
uh I don't think you need to make that
to snatch those people I think you need
to hashtag just one to say you have that
style game on your platform it doesn't
necessarily mean on trying to get those
people because those people are gonna
stay on Playstation regardless but you
need to be this type of experiences on
your platform in some way yeah 11
million that's great
um some of them give any thoughts on um
you know PlayStation
right now
32 million eight that's Christmas
console sales of 83 gear oil
that's crazy it's crazy
so we're going to talk about the Xbox
numbers with this stuff no we ain't
gonna worry about that
you pass numbers
[Laughter]
when a game of this caliber sells that
many copies that quickly
you got to open your eyes a little bit
because it is I mean I've always said it
should say say more about Last of Us
than I should say about this because
last of us two years to get to this yeah
yeah I mean it to me it is one of those
things I've always felt like why do
first party games not have an even
bigger attach rate as I've always
thought because I'm like well it's it's
the reason supposedly that you buy the
console for right but it's not it's only
to the hardcore So eventually you're
gonna Plateau right because for whatever
reason like if you have you know 30
million PlayStations out there my
thinking is well you don't have 25
million God of War so because that's
what people buy the console for that's
incorrect that's what we buy the console
for that's not what everybody else buys
people buy it for third-party stuff
exactly 99 of people just play mostly
third-party stuff it's like I've said
for a while so who it's not a
coincidence that whoever owns that Call
of Duty marketing usually wins the
generation yeah because it's quality
duty is just no matter good bad whatever
it's gonna sell so to see this game so
sell that quickly is impressive even if
it is whatever how many on PS4 bundles
whatever it's impressive and
it goes to show that Sony doesn't that
not yet anyway they still don't have to
bend to what Microsoft is doing and even
though they dip their toes in with a
little bit of you know a little bit of a
little bit of game pass by a little bit
of Game Pass flavor in in their PS plus
a little bit of that you know but they
show they don't want to do that if
you're at the top tier of PS plus you
are starving right now they they're not
giving you anything that you care about
you paying extra for for one like one
PSP game every five months for real
because I'm there and I'm like oh you're
not giving me nothing nothing all the
damn thing if you're if you're in the
middle tier you get you eaten but uh but
if you've been on that platform you
probably have a lot of those games well
that's the thing right how long are they
gonna wait before they have an excuse to
be like you know this ain't working
right this is something
I gotta say though it is that thing like
the Sony name when you talk about the
cache they have and the and the cushion
they have that they've earned so
sometimes I get mad at it because I'm
like yo come on like but it's that
PlayStation name it resonates and people
like oh PlayStation they automatically
use this and now now what they've done
is with this type of game right third
person over the show The Action game
what they've done is they created a
situation where in people's minds
quality means that hello on the
Something song
[Music]
but I've always said to really beat
PlayStation you have to beat them at
their game and beat them soundly in
order to be like oh PlayStation is
slipping they're falling off
it's interesting they could do whatever
they could do all the anti-consumer
practices
nickel and dime you is not gonna matter
that's right they like it and this game
proves all of it I don't know okay I
will push back a little bit on that
because I do feel like if they get their
hands on that Call of Duty marketing and
that game pass I think that's one of the
only things that might be like we don't
care what you got well you you got the
the the Colossal giant no goodness right
but but it goes back to what kind of
game is doing that it's a third-party
game it's a third party Colossus it's
not a first party game so
you know we know they have a bunch of
multiplayer games coming they go again
dip in the toe and see what works uh I
don't know how long this PS plus
experiment is Gonna Last with all these
extra tiers I don't know if that's gonna
stick around 29th but yeah
um
and like I said play having played it
like all day yesterday and really having
a chance to sit with it the quality the
quality does sort of I I I I can't it is
definitely not a BT a game it's not oh
yeah but remember the one Lord so
um he was playing on a PlayStation 5 or
Playstation 4. you had the same
experience PlayStation five places okay
my son playing on PlayStation 4 Pro same
experience
[Music]
how many was sold on the PlayStation 5.
um we don't have that breakdown damn it
I don't see it he's like cool damn
inside yeah how many was sold on the
PlayStation 4. that's a good question I
don't have that damn it sir
they didn't get it oh
well
um
what we do and we can extrapolate from
the numbers
[Music]
30 million you mean assume
we're gonna give you these are hard
numbers they told you that they had 30
million PlayStation 5 sold right we're
gonna stand on that right hello
stand on that there we go 30 million
sold so we know that they got 130
PlayStation 4s right
so stand on that let's get that oh man
so that's 160 right 160 of the fan base
well hello people 160 at a fan base only
11 million and you do showed up only in
three Buffs only let me let me check it
check it it was eating Popeye biscuits
till this thing showed up so 11 million
came outside because it was hungry and
they definitely needed something to eat
so what I'm gonna say is in a vacuum it
looks fantastic and I love it I love it
11 million that purchased how many of
those people finish that game let's see
let's say four percent so it was just
people that wanted to be an excite guys
those people that wanted to be in and
know those people that wanted to say I
have this game I'm here do you have can
you extrapolate the numbers the four
percent that finished again I would love
it because I got the game and I didn't
finish it
so your number is reflective okay
I can do it right I can do the numbers
right here with this panel that we have
one in four to finish this game right
because addict finished it did you
did you he's the only one did not finish
it
I didn't finish it and uh Cog didn't
finish it so one in four finished this
game which represents
we represent the blood of uh what's
going on in the PlayStation Nation so
the Gunnies
baby we outside all right 11 million
sold we don't know what the numbers
break down to but what I do say is this
and I'm not surprised that they went up
in numbers
automatically when shipment is loose
after they raised the price they raised
the price
uh now shipments is uh
now we got sisters available the price
is raised funny
some people would say that's a weird
business tactic but it works it works
these dudes fall for it's fantastic all
these systems are sold all right let's
go to your your service numbers
it went down
but you sold more yes so your tax rate
is funky
so we purchased the box but nobody
really won a patron your service
but they do want to patreon your game
now Sony a little word of advice if that
game was available
day one inside your service your numbers
would have went up um I do want to point
out uh BG it has some has some stats in
the chat for you oh I didn't see it it's
not in color
S
I can't
see I got on Shades uh yeah continue but
the fact of the matter is this the fact
of the matter is this Sony's gonna keep
doing what they're doing because they're
y'all allow it and I love it I love it I
love it but to act like this is a a
overwhelming successes fantastic listen
listen
overwhelming success this is crazy
they're doing unprecedented stuff
they're knocking it out the park yes
I really respect it but had it been a
PlayStation 5 only game
I would have stood on my Square last
year that's crazy I don't know if 8
million
I don't know if 9 million PlayStation 4.
I don't know if 10.5 million sold on the
PlayStation 4. I got you 500 000.
PlayStation five dudes
dub if they ain't really giving numbers
your dudes is the Dude Where's the
numbers for Horizon where's the system
numbers for Xbox
transparent so what you're saying is
because they've been quiet you say they
church mouse and all right they know
what they do so you said Horizon
basically you can't beat six okay they
ring the bell when the bell is needed to
be rung right they're gonna yell out we
sold 11 million well who doesn't give me
that
give me the breakdown of how many
PlayStation 4 dudes is really important
to your numbers
we want to exclude the PlayStation 4
dudes do your numbers really look good
under the lights
is the juice really worse The Squeeze is
it really what you saying I hear what
you're doing In fairness but can I say
the fact that this was not a multi-plat
in the ecosystem and not on PC in the
short amount of time it's not impressive
sir Cog beautiful I got it you got it
add it got it right we all on
I want to know how many is PlayStation 4
dudes okay fair fair that's it just give
me the numbers give me the 8 million of
PlayStation 4 dudes that went out there
and got that and let's let those
PlayStation 5 dudes you know let them
sit on the side ring the bell cause it
ain't really y'all ain't really ringing
the bell like that [__]
don't pump up your chest little man is
carrying y'all y'all little messy we got
a little man too that carry us right
you'll be upset when we put little man
numbers up take away them PlayStation 4.
you gotta do this
if little man is really caring all right
all right so so hold up I put a poll in
the chat is God of War numbers
impressive yes or no all right I see it
I see what he want to know that's right
before he gives so then so all right
let's say this so the next guaranteed
PS5 exclusive whatever it is if they do
similarly you're gonna love the poem If
they do similar numbers then you like
all right then I respect them okay but
you will respect this yo this is five
years the little man support okay
little man little man is supporting
these numbers because you take little
man out the equation I guarantee those
numbers would have been like three
million okay so because of PS4 clutch
generation title
just to clarify the 30 million plus
they've sold of uh Playstation fives you
think that only three million
dollars
you know why I know they they cheap
right so the PlayStation 4 dudes that
was sitting there saying I don't see
nothing on the PlayStation 5 yet that I
need to go get they went out of got it
because they knew God of War was coming
for the PlayStation 4. so they didn't
have to Pony up and go get a PlayStation
well I mean I'm just saying
they're not called ponies no more they
call Gunnies that's what they call
Gunnies man they got gunny face right so
this this is what happens this is what
happens when you still cross platform
you're able to manipulate your numbers
how you want to manipulate it if that
joint was only on Playstation five tell
me what was that game that little circus
card game that they were jumping out
they was doing and they put it
all right the one thing the one thing I
was the one thing I will say is
I get where you're coming from you know
people supporting the PlayStation 5 but
you're acting like them buying on PS4s
and supporting it like I'm not saying
yeah that's kind of what you act like
just because but then why would the
PlayStation 5 copies is the one that
really matters listen to me I'm not
saying that what I'm saying is I'm
taking whatever arrows that you're
throwing and I'm moving it see Sovereign
knows me more than anybody he knew this
was coming he's not moving to the side
he's watching he's watching me work
see what you what you don't understand
is you still mystified
the magic trick is you so you served me
a huge L and I took your L and I flipped
it around turned it into a w
but you didn't realize is that when that
you thought was really blood in your
socks I feel that listening we gotta see
all I'm all I'm hearing is excuses
PlayStation 4 contingency
King's that person that that like
screams there's someone in the in the
bleachers and then runs in the back door
I'm the person that stand right there
and tell the dude in the bleachers he
ain't ready for the smoke
but uh look impressive you know the
short times PlayStation 4 dudes is a
hell of impressive
it's a massive Commercial Success you
know that's hand over fish money so
salute to them
full version Oh my god
well that's the reason that uh you know
they they let that as a cross play game
because they they do yeah they it's a
cross-platform game because Sony
themself agree with it
to make sure that game so this is what
makes your little Spider-Man talk
irrelevant they think they're gonna
build up all the way to it and they're
gonna start seeing those sales I cannot
wait to happen
and you're gonna see Spider-Man show up
on the PlayStation 4 because what
happens PlayStation 4 lives matter
isn't it gonna be fantastic when I have
Platinum King knees hanging right what's
crazy is
sitting right here they're Gonna Shine
more than my monitor
so like every day like you don't respect
your PlayStation 4 dude just you don't
just know occasionally chat you're gonna
see me get up and I'm just gonna have to
shine
is here but then when I get them
Platinum knees from winning that next
but I gotta make sure those are really
shine yeah yeah I appreciate it
PlayStation 4 lives matter beat
so back to my bars um yeah so like I
said hashtag just one energy just want
to let y'all know
um 11 million people feel this way about
this kind of genre yeah so it seems like
this kind of genre it's popping don't
you love how it all goes back together
because the people that come at me and
they're like why let's see
like this maybe maybe
to have one of those you know what I'm
saying just have one at all maybe two
maybe
like I said salute to any apparently
they're doing the God of War movie
[Music]
when you see when you see Last of Us on
SNL yeah you know it's next
we got to move on that's what I got from
yeah
there's a lot of super chats yeah
I got ko3 black truth two dollars Super
Chat uh didn't Titanfall Titanfall one
sell 10 million copies though
Xbox one you got this theme or something
oh my God excuse me
all the same thing yeah span bro like
don't give me 20 years spam
why can't we give God award credit for
doing it in three months who's not
giving it I said how many PlayStation 4s
did that bro oh my God
be patient you got to be patient we're
building our case
we remove the PlayStation 4 numbers from
the equation wouldn't have reported
anything
I know you're ready but you got to be
patient you gotta let them cook right
now we gotta yeah we gotta let him cook
he's got a little cut we know what he's
doing we know what he's doing we're
gonna let him cook put it in your pocket
it's cool the only thing I'm gonna think
about is these Platinum knees right here
that's all I'm thinking you better stop
thinking
there we go hold on a second we got Lord
Metroid remember for 16 months Lord
silver I will not allow the Nintendo
slander earlier uh
tears of the Kingdom right here's the
kingdom was the best-selling game this
year and Game of the Year as well salute
to the chat and Lawrence you're probably
right I I can't even deny that we'll see
here we'll see
truth once again five dollars Titanfall
to fail because the multiplayer was mid
they missed those Azure servers
no Azure back then I will say that I
enjoyed the TitanFall ones multiplayer
more than two
um my favorite mode was last time I felt
like it wasn't like that let me ask you
a question do you like Apex uh Legends
uh multiplayer more than you like
Titanfalls
um yeah Titanfall one no uh Titanfall 2
yes okay all right so we can't go back
to Titanfall one so you like it more
than you like tiger why can't we okay
you asked me a question with a load a
gun yeah you know I asked you a question
with a gun that was aimed at you yeah
that oh my God
yo I'ma tell you if y'all want to have
interrupts per second yo bro
clap backs today
or Focus bro that Focus work I've never
seen you ready on everything like I'll
tell you how much time you have how many
scoops did you have to me yeah
listen I put one scoop in the first time
okay right and I've been adding water
and then I put the other scoop in the
second time for the day that's it that's
it for today
ounce per scoop but please you know I've
been having a ball I have I have five
days eight hours and 11 minutes in in
Apex Legends oh you do absolute what
that mean come on
is when it comes to the Apex Legends
brand I could talk about it what's your
time how much do you have in Titan for
oh there you go
you know you know what this is called
this is like this is like 90s King yeah
yeah this is not bro we got that he on
that event he's sitting there telling me
relevant numbers
I got five days in Apex London how many
days you got Titan for that'll tell you
why your game got canceled
good to you then we got raka 23 ten
dollars for chat third person PPE based
Apex Legends game that bangs only helps
build the universe think bigger than
just the multiplayer all can exist in
the universe multiple things can be true
exist and win that is my thinking damn
it but oh I can't even see the TitanFall
because I took it off the store oh wow
what happened to that
[Laughter]
PS5 is stomping out the Xbox series
consoles get out of here okay
you're being extra that's a bit much
Microsoft didn't give you all they hard
numbers
you dudes brought one console when it
launched and y'all out had capping for
the 11 dudes that came out 11 million
dudes that came out and purchase B stop
it man you wasn't part of the 30 million
you didn't even grow the fan base those
are 30 million scalpers you want to see
oh I saved this for you I saved this I
was waiting for you to track your number
all your choices in the store it's in
the store on the shelves ready for sale
this doesn't indicate
so stop it stop tapping I don't see
nothing like this for Xbox please
somebody give me a picture of Xboxes in
the store like this please show me
because they're being played your joints
is Right nobody's online with you dudes
like that 30 days 32 million Scouts yes
we get it we get it scalpers don't worry
give us a couple more months
McCain might as well I just did a
fatality
man you know what I really like what's
the indication of successful Platforms
in the sell-through how you sold more
but your service is down that means
dudes got your joint left them in the
box with resale oh nobody buying them
nobody's actually sitting here copping
like oh we want to get this service
listen when a kid get their joint at
home they want to have everything right
so they're gonna take the 1999
if you would have told me he's
extrapolated y'all went up but service
went down so how you gonna buy more but
your service go down
he was ready for this time he's ready to
take away all the Joy from PlayStation
numbers on this Xbox and selling but
Game Pass numbers is going up make the
math math B make the map yes Financial
numbers with cake there we go hold up
hold up hold up King do you think
starfield's gonna sell just as much oh
man you keep extending keep extending
this bro you said do I think stop you
think star Phil's gonna sell just as
much as God Awards gonna stomp it out
and you're gonna get the real numbers
of the real numbers so what exactly what
do you consider stomping out what do you
consider stomping out when Microsoft
released their numbers then you'll see
how stomping goes but but I want your
definition to stomp it
um
11 million right yeah they're gonna
stomp them out oh so are we talking like
15 million I'm talking you're talking
about a real game versus the dlcb
do I I I feel like addict is alluding to
reaching Souls he's alluding to some
knees that he wants he's trying to do a
bend and need something crazy you're
feeling himself
yo I can tell you this being okay since
you want to play the game
since you want to play the game put the
fraud alerts a [__] all right sir since
you want to play I want to see how tough
you really are
really um
listen listen since your mouth is so
strong today
since you won't have strong mouths
check it out check it out we're gonna
take your PlayStation 5 sales uh
PlayStation 5 only on God of War and
we're gonna put that up against the Xbox
series consoles sellers but you we don't
know what the PlayStation 5 numbers are
don't listen like you're literally
putting conditions that we can't do
listen don't worry
[Music]
this is this is it see this is what you
do
you thought those numbers you thought
the PlayStation 4 was gonna save you so
tell me PS5 numbers
no don't isolate me tell me PS5 numbers
Mr Know It All Mr Enlightenment that's
right numbers we don't have the
PlayStation 5 numbers I just want you to
take this deal what's the best ability
star Fields series numbers versus your
PlayStation 5 God of War numbers three
months
mm-hmm
this is that moment
it's that moment yes
the PlayStation 4 holding your buttocks
and holding you up
he literally can't meet the conditions
yeah
both of y'all what's funny what's funny
hold up what's funny is he wants me to
make a bet on unknown variables on my
end of the best
he wants his into the back to be
unknown variables we don't know how much
it's gonna sell for three months right
I'm the one that's sitting here behind
so what happens if you guys don't
announce the number you already got a
three million what happens if they don't
announce the numbers
and stuff right now too many variables
let's move on let's move on let's let's
agree to move on because he's scared
okay
for one year five dollars majority don't
mean nothing until I see percentages
it could be 60 40. also Pokemon had zero
bundles here we go again
real quick uh deep down anime get on
patreon real quick I need to ask you a
question oh okay there we go also uh
Pokemon has zero bundles Elden ring had
zero bundles but it's still good yep
and we have remedy live four pound 49.
now let's play your account not sales
please stop talking
yeah
just an upris PS4 game that the Fanboys
got stiff for uh stop this is true
it's running over there 95. stop
stop it's season four
we love you continue yeah we got done a
taco member for one year five dogs
what about Horizon Callisto ratchet
returnal Etc all Cog is proven is that
if your AAA single player doesn't get 93
plus on Metacritic it's underperforming
never said that stop that stop making
excuses like I thought I hate stop the
what aboutism where's the just one for
Xbox that's let's get to it stop
worrying about what other people doing
or worry about what I asked y'all keep
dancing around that that's all I got to
say continue
there we go slow go back slap remember
for two months two dollar Super Chat 45
beat the game 32 completed the epilogue
damn
okay it's pretty decent
remedy live with eight pound 99 pen
Super Chat when Fanboys hear new games
coming all they know it's a third person
action game with an easy Platinum that
requires time and not skills they all
butter up their uh their
theirs they all butter up their blanks
and prep to go two fingers and two nose
deep wow that's extra what does that
poll say God what the pole at
oh
that's why I do that voice because it's
it's it's the chat when it comes to you
um
then we got called weeb ten dollars to
protect come on King 45 percent of
players have the trophy for beating why
are you spoiling out here obviously but
still repeating somebody 16 have a
trophy for beating someone else so we
can't assume about 60 of the game got
game with a bundle and don't care about
the game could be also if people get it
with a bundle and you don't care about
that game you just download fortnite
um
wait someone agrees with me that the
numbers are a little all forgot about
Ragnarok I was expecting 10 plus million
retail sales and the bundle would add
like four to five million 14 to 15
million so you're saying it's low for
what you thought it would be
interesting oh interesting it's three
months on like that's crazy but you know
it's not impressive not impressive not
impressive
there we have Donna Taco again remember
for uh one year father's chat Pokemon
was an overwhelming success Animal
Crossing was an overwhelming success
smash was an overwhelming success this
was so many breaking even oh wow the
truth ain't the devil Let It Be and
Playstation 4 numbers is crazy 11
million sales on a 70 game that they
don't have to share anywhere anybody is
they broke even not impressive
billion this is a billion dollar budget
again
and I'm only doing this because Cog
never goes this hard for Nintendo when
they do these numbers twice a year bro I
don't know I don't pick the time I could
only pick one there's three other Lords
that don't talk about Nintendo numbers I
respect it though respect page 23 bkny
20 loss with that Xbox raise prices of
the series consoles in India and Japan
yes they have Microsoft canceled
Coalition two projects Microsoft raised
prizes of their games Microsoft doesn't
release Game Pass numbers it's stagnant
Xbox management is terrible and wow okay
thank you I love it I love it for the
detailed list they don't release those
numbers but um Sony did release their
numbers and they down a million go over
there and join us
oh my God and subscribe to the services
and we have Tom from Toonami five
gonna be crazy seeing attic space with
that midnight PlayStation Vlog drop
saying Spider-Man 2 coming out for PS4
and in that case it's a wrap and I'll
come on here and I'll give him that bend
the knee thing but I have a feeling what
ends up gonna happen is is the Platinum
knee is going to be right here let me
get the Nintendo dudes right quick shout
out to Metroid he said yeah [__] why are
you not doing Nintendo I can only pick
one topic sir my topic was the Sony
numbers right yeah there's three other
Lords on this paddle that don't seem to
want to talk about Nintendo numbers so
why don't we ask them you know it's dope
yes you had to pick what you felt that
was gonna sell
[Laughter]
your decision
here's the thing none of us really care
about ourselves but king king's the one
that used conversation I care about
people that talk about them yeah
just like but we do talk about the games
of Nintendo and I think that's more
important this guy here he's trying to
be a purist now
all we do is talk about here is of a
Nintendo no I'm being realistic go on
our go on our Channel we have plenty of
games that we reviewed that are Nintendo
I'm being realistic about it but what
he's saying is how come you ain't
talking about him
okay quick then we got stop drinking
that King yeah yo sip that bro
I'm telling you he jumped in a job
machine yeah I've never seen him this
back and forth in years he's not playing
today this focus is what it is y'all
y'all want to be focused as well please
join me
here we go broken games HDR five dollar
super chat if God of War sales are bad
then the majority of games of failures
cyberpunk Elden ring even breath of the
wild failed based on percentages and
install thank you appreciate it I didn't
say that it was bad
what I did say BG is that remove those
PlayStation numbers and then you can get
the bad
but it's a never mind do not continue
please
I got jumped uh okay the next one I have
after BG's
is
Donna Taco tell me if I missed anything
after BG don't I have I have done a taco
five dollar Super Chat why don't we have
a topic for Xbox having more Mau than
PlayStation with half the consoles it's
almost it's almost like the ecosystem is
more than console
okay we had five six topics already you
have seven no we're not we're moving on
yeah
exactly then we have any did I miss
anything had it
uh I don't know I can't see because I
share the screen for the packs
um
I want them to see it all right all
right I just don't want to help my man
with the super chance and stop beef or
whatever
and we got rocket 23 ten dollars of
attack King is on point like a fax
machine peep the message got a PS5 and a
joint still in the box not saying it's
bad just saying it's still in the box
still new and unopened continue please
thank you sir are we good void luck five
dollars Super Chat majority of y'all
have not finished God of War why do you
need a hashtag just one for Xbox stop
the cat why are you mad that that game
can't exist why are you capping for the
game not existing what does finishing
the game
like that is the stupidest logic like I
hate to come at people but it's like bro
I play games in the order I want to play
them they're talking about move on let's
go
than we have done a taco again five
dollars it makes sense Nintendo having
impressive sales is not news because it
always happens it's new for PlayStation
that's quite the topic
oh my God you're done just so move the
PlayStation 4 numbers
just check out right after BG's and see
if I missed anything between that and
Donald tacos why don't we have a topic
for Xbox yeah I have to go to the actual
screen okay oh yeah we're caught up
we're good all right did you get the
dawn of Taco one you got that one yeah
Donald taco right after BG
um they got uh smelly recipe oh you see
I missed that five dollars cell numbers
don't always equal to a quality game
take that cyber Punk launch for example
[Music]
there's another Donut Taco for five
dollars
okay okay yeah okay I just missed one
cool yep we got up all right thank you
all right cool cool okay let's get a
topic let me uh set you up because no
one would think the last one was his
topic yeah there's multiple topics this
week
so yeah it looked like um two things all
can't want to talk about PlayStation
Plus collection first
um it looks like they coming uh on the
PlayStation uh blog they said they want
to provide an update on the PlayStation
Plus collection that has been offered as
a benefit to PlayStation Members Plus
members on PS5 since 2020. on May 9th
the PlayStation Plus collection will no
longer be offered if you haven't
redeemed the titles in this collection
you can still do so before May 9 which
will then enable you to access those
titles even after this date for as long
as you remain a PlayStation plus member
so PlayStation Plus
um collection looks like it is going
away and that was the one that gave you
all like the 19 titles
um do a lot of those really good games
last of us rematched this part of their
um bloodborne god of war and so on and
so forth and then the second
um part of King's topic was PlayStation
5 on the VR pre-orders it says report is
that Sony slashed PlayStation VR2
production after disappointing
pre-orders and um looks like Bloomberg
tries to collaborate the story they say
that um Pi Pro seems to be a limiting
factor for wider adoption
um Sony Court reduced projections for
the initial launch of its psvr too
dramatically after early pre-orders
disappointings disappointed signaling
little Improvement for the hype but
unproven virtual reality sector
um the company half this 4K forecast for
shipments of the psvr2 which is set for
February 22nd release this quarter is
about about I mean about a million units
that people familiar with its
deliberations so so they have previously
aimed to have two billion units ready
for launch and that um yeah as they said
that they told a Tokyo based electronic
giant told Supply Partners to expect
reduced display panel orders according
to the people the company now plans to
ship around 1.5 million between um April
and March so these are to the end there
is a follow-up
Sony did come out to dispute the claim
and they said a Saudi spokesman
initially declined to comment saying
that the company does not describe
discuss product inventory but then the
company has said that they did not cut
PlayStation Vue on two production
numbers and it's seeing enthusiasm from
PlayStation fans for the upcoming launch
so this started a little bit of a debate
what was the pr do name
exactly
we didn't do that
there's a bit of a debate there
obviously um shout out to um Christopher
uh drink um I thought you might say
shout out to Christopher Hart
you know so pretty much the debate is is
the Nuance would be that would be the
production numbers are they not the same
as the sales forecast and then some
people are saying it's clever wording by
Sony but it doesn't directly refute the
Bloomberg report so King this is your
topic PlayStation Plus or uh collection
looks like it's going away and then the
VR2 numbers seems to be reduced so check
this out right you sold record
PlayStation 5.
would it behoove you to just say let
them keep what what's already there
what's already working
we're already you know we're building up
a whole uh catalog for just for
PlayStation 5 on it
how come they're eliminating
the thing that's just for PlayStation 5
people if you have a PlayStation 4 you
can't go play Demon Souls right now you
know you need a PlayStation 5 but on May
9th
we did not partake you won't be able to
partake so
sales numbers is down when it comes to
their service
they're removing something that's
integral
to the PlayStation 5's ecosystem the
PlayStation 5. not Sony's ecosystem
because the PlayStation 4 can't access
it right
and then
we get word that they're cutting back on
production of the PlayStation VR2
that everybody was hyped about
they hit me five times in my email yo
it's coming out in uh February 22
subscribe get it man your king please it
didn't bother me one time
not one time but I got five separate
emails yo um hey man we see that you
have a PlayStation account and um we
were launching the VR and we want to
know hey man don't miss out on your
opportunity the opportunity is still
available
so apparently everybody felt like me
at least a million of y'all did right
said nah I'll get it when it's when it's
priced accordingly it's never going to
be priced according to me you have a
tethered device that is actually needs a
PlayStation 5. to run
so you got to factor in the 600 for a
Playstation 5. 600 for the the I told
you I was gonna be twelve hundred
dollars for the PlayStation 2 VR you're
just in it
to get into this ecosystem no back
compact the joint is DOA and the numbers
indicated that it's going to be dead on
arrival I don't expect it to sell the 5
million at the PlayStation uh one VR
sold I expected to sell probably top out
at 3 million this seems to be somebody's
passion project what I say is why with
so much success so much sales numbers
everything is astronomical right this is
where I told y'all never believe
anything Sony says let them let them go
by their actions their actions showed
you that the PlayStation 5 isn't selling
like you think it is so we got to remove
these games out of here make them buy
them right make them purchase we can't
give it to free because these dudes
ain't really doing what they supposed to
do pull it out let them buy so that's
because there's no reason for that stuff
to leave on May 9th no reason at all
and why are they taking a short on the
psvr twos shipments because the people
that are taking the orders telling you
yeah they cut the shipment in half
because I'll be pissed off if you told
me that you copying for me a couple of
statues cop in 10 statues for me and I'm
like I got 10 statues sold out the door
and then you come back to me and say nah
I can only do five
what happened to your forecast before
all right so you messing with my wallet
so understandably the the the the the
the makers the manufacturers will be
pissed off that's where the information
came out of course Sony would say no we
never did that of course they would say
that but where's the dude's name
attached to that
since they're so successful
how come they're doing these things that
indicate success isn't what you've seen
um
oh yeah there it is
I just used King's terma hey we're in an
economic downturn
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh I mean go ahead Eddie go ahead be
real quick the only the only remote VR
that I'm even remotely comfortable using
is the Quest 2 and until I see uh you
know games which is first off uh do I
see games games games you think guys
they they got they got our people DME
over there and that's good Obama need to
see more than demio because guess what I
got DME on the quest and the PC so I
need to see more than that you know I
don't want no on Rails type of game I
need to see unique experiences I can
only have on the VR that I care about
that's pretty much all it is you know I
I don't care what they do this on I
don't care about no pre-order I ain't
buying it till I see stuff that I want
to play and that's all and what about
the PlayStation Plus collection going
away midnight
I mean it's it's interesting that
they're getting rid of stuff that they
don't have to get rid of like that they
own that cost them nothing uh but it's
just like you know what king always be
saying you know they they don't care
about that service it doesn't seem like
the I feel like the only reason they
combine the service is the way they did
is because the numbers look bad on
PlayStation now and it looks better now
that they combined to the services with
PlayStation Plus but it's just like look
like a lot of things don't make sense
there's games right now that they own
that they could easily put in that
service that's been out for a while it
is what it is you know you don't like it
there's a there's a service for you it's
called Game Pass uh you know if you if
you feel that strong about them making
sure games are in there wow games should
be in there you got to go with Xbox now
if you want to go over there on
Playstation where it just seems to be
inconsistency you can't really complain
at that point because you're used to it
yeah
soft your thoughts PlayStation Plus
collection going away and Playstation 2
VR pre-order numbers yeah so the PS plus
connection collection
um I grew addicting that like 10 out of
those 19 games in that collection belong
to them
so they should be able to stay in the in
the service right so the other ones
obviously it's licensing maybe that
licensing ran out they don't want to
continue to pay for it whatever
um so
if you could separate those out and keep
your 10
did our first party you should do that
now if the PlayStation Plus collection
is is is under a skew like there is a
you know a skew that says PS plus
collection then if the licensing runs
out on some of those things and the
whole thing has to go as a collection
right so I don't know if they have it uh
if they have it broken down that way
where the PS plus connection is kind of
its own like TM SKU
um if that is the case I can I see why
the whole thing has to go and they can't
separate out certain things so that's
that but apart from that like whatever a
lot of those games seem to me like
they're in that middle tier as well
uh so that that could be part of it as
well but again it's just bad Optics and
they don't care about Optics it's
something they've been giving people
that jump onto the PS5 platform it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
looking at it on a surface level
business stuff you know is behind us
behind the scenes it makes sense why it
might not be there for you know forever
I get that now the psvr two stuff
remember I said I said it a while back
it's like yep I'm the only dude that has
it that's going to be there day one and
nobody else
um but yeah I mean it makes sense when
you look at the landscape
you're selling a piece of a piece of
peripheral hardware for more than the
actual Hardware that that's needed to
run at costs that's just never a good
look that's just never a good look
so when you look at you know and when
you look at the lineup the only thing
that stands out is their first party
game which is of course they call it a
mountain call it a mountain there's
nothing else there they didn't so far
the work doesn't seem like it's been
done to get Half-Life Alex on there
another transformative game the work
seems like it hasn't been done to get
bone works on there another
transformative game
you know they they're bringing the the
other stuff that you expect but you know
a good percentage of that is available
on other platforms that are cheaper and
not tethered right
so I just don't see when you look at the
landscape yeah I grew King I don't think
it's gonna make that 500. unless oh that
5 million I I just kind of I don't
if they don't have a more of a
dedication to it first party wise which
is the only reason I really went for it
I'm like you know what if PlayStation
focuses on making games I want I want
that right I want that because you know
they're going to wall it off it's not
going to be everywhere they're not gonna
make these games to appear on on the on
the meta Quest or anyplace else it's
going to be PlayStation so that's what I
wanted to see what happened real quick
so if um I don't see I I assume you
member chatted because it's not a super
chat uh I might have missed it I'm
looking at the super chats I don't see
your name so if it was a member chat I
can't see those so go ahead and add IOP
and say what you said in the membership
yeah we're gonna make that right don't
flip out we got you um it's not that we
ignore anything what happens is there's
so many that come in at once sometimes
one falls through the crowd yeah they
jump up and they'll skip it and it won't
let us and it won't let me scroll back
to it in real time they really need to
have a place where you can see those
member chat because besides is that chat
the the live chat you can't see those
member chats anywhere on YouTube on
YouTube you got it okay so now he said
no worries yeah put what you said be Lou
we got yeah just what we just said we'll
read it we don't mind reading it no you
hoping against hope because hasn't been
shown that Sony doesn't support any of
their peripherals that's the that's the
worry right I mean the history haven't
been good
to worry that is the fact that is a fact
till now and the worry is that it will
continue right and especially if the
numbers aren't there you can see them
running away if the numbers aren't there
and let's say one of those one of those
multiplayer games service games hits
crazy we talked about we talked about
the calculus
after a while the calculator's gonna be
like all right forget it we're not going
to keep focusing on this all right I'll
play this with you
and uh did you get the PlayStation VR1
I I ultimately did not get it okay
and it had more games
than this thing that they're launching
right now more exclusive yeah to begin
with no I'm gonna defer to you the
Batman all that stuff to happen yeah
exclusive stuff
I mean because it was really at that
period of time he was really pretty much
just game in there unless you had an
Oculus or your Vibe or whatever and I
had those things but their stuff was a
little bit you know just singular to
them I feel that um you had you know
um a lot of games just for them what I'm
seeing from this fake industry 30
because the yellow 30 right only third
you got 30 games yeah those 30 Games
mean something to you if you don't have
an Oculus right if you haven't partaked
in other VR I feel what you're saying
now being that you have I'm just curious
about you know solve being that you have
and you probably got the majority of
those games so the only game you're
gonna probably be looking at is maybe
the demio and maybe well definitely the
horizon
the only games I'm looking at is Horizon
and you know the the makers of what what
the golfs yeah they have one called what
the bat they're supposed to come out so
it's a baseball theme so you know I'm
gonna do that that's pretty much it got
two games so you're gonna spend 600 plus
yep seven seven or seven or some change
knowing that their history would back in
their peripherals it's not good it's
zero like because all of that peripheral
you you you literally have a junkyard
full of the peripherals right and if
they only just stuck with it not one
peripheral
that they said was coming out did they
say you know what we're going to cut
expectations on it and and drop it back
from the beginning not one from the
beginning no so this thing is DOA even
from their own standards I think they're
just too too far into it that they have
to you know finish this commitment
they're not going to admit to that
having to have dude done that you're
never going to get the straight answer
from them that they had to internally
cut prices oh cut projections and then I
gotta do that no I'm sorry so my thing
is
do you feel that that one million that
they did commit to was something that
was contractually they had to just keep
at least half of that order that they
put in because they already made the
commitment
I mean I'm assuming every time they have
to you know sit down with Foxconn to
determine what they're going to make
there has to be a minimum number that
Foxconn is going to make to to accept
the order right I don't care if they've
been working together forever it's still
it has to be cost effective for them to
be able to make them so yeah that's got
to be a minimum number I don't know if
it's a million
um could be half of that yeah
um but yeah there's definitely a minimum
number I think it definitely has to be
less especially for br I'm assuming VR
is just a different metric because you
can't be like if you if you have the
same deal in place for that the console
proper right
a million minimum it makes sense to me
VR it would just make sense that the
that the base number is lower right no I
get it we'll see man we'll see I'll be
there day one I heard great things about
Call of the mountain and yeah
yeah same thing it's to King's Point
he's making valid point this is not
trolling this is valid points you know
that he's saying about the history and
what's going on and then we got to be
real about the adoption rates you know
what I mean and um look you know for me
it's it's it's kind of like softball I'm
buying it based on the potential of what
I think they could do if they commit
right so
I'm like solving a sense that one thing
we love about them I'm always on I love
their hashtag just one energy so part of
me wants to see that in a VR space so
call them out and excites me and I want
to see how that goes obviously the early
reports are positive I will say to your
point King I didn't get PS4 VR1 for a
different reason
I didn't like
I felt that they were trying to
repurpose old peripherals and it wasn't
a true commitment to VR and what I mean
by that is if you remember the the moves
yeah the moves that didn't work and then
the camera that didn't necessarily work
from you know on its own you know as a
sales success then became coupled
together as a VR experience with the the
actual first one so I just wanted more
of the hand-to-hand tracking more of the
like I didn't feel the tracking systems
really I felt like somebody had leftover
move sticks and was like yo let's see
yeah they're not going that far but you
know I mean technically that's what it
was it was it was yeah it was a dipping
of the toe right yeah what what their
name and their cachet I'm feeling like
look it's good for them to come in and
to try to grow the space because
obviously the space is still trying to
you know trying to grow trying to find
it does anybody know do they come with a
demo this like the first one came with a
demo disc right that show the underwater
stuff right it showed that uh like that
what was that game it was like a
gangster game it showed a whole bunch of
other different things do they come with
a demo disc this one because it said so
the underwater stuff was really good
that was really scary yeah I don't know
so I mean look I pre-ordered it I'm
excited I want to see what oh you went
on it too yeah
I'm not in it right well I got three
statues
they bothered me three times I didn't
see the value I got three statues up I
got uh what what let me see Captain
America Iron Man and Thor
anybody want to make that trade I'll
give you those three steps Captain
America Iron Man and Thor send me the
PlayStation VR2 we rent and I'll unbox
it and I'll put your face on all right
no doubt oh my God I'm not trying to
give them no money all right it is what
it is the last part I'll say as far as
the I'm actually more I'm gonna say
bothered a little disappointed that the
PlayStation Plus collection is going to
wear uh that's disgusting because I felt
like even though I know they weren't
quote unquote claiming they were
initially trying to make a competitor
game pass but right we see eventually
they did with the the different layers
of PlayStation Plus but like the
collection I remember when I got my PS5
and I'm like yo this is mad value like
off the rip look at these games that
they've given you they were giving you
what bloodborne days gone Detroit God of
War Infamous Second Son Ratchet and
Clank last score Last of Us remastered
until doing untrip charted four that was
from first party then third party they
giving you Arkham Knight Battlefield
Crash Bandicoot fall out for Monster
Hunter Resident Evil Persona 5 Mortal
Kombat all of this is as soon as you
just bought a system yeah like that was
insane value I'm like yo people don't I
felt like people wasn't talking about
PlayStation Plus collection enough I
thought that was the only reason why I
even jumped into that test yeah I was
like bro that that is really a good
value to have all these games off the
rip if you a brand new PS5 let's say you
missed out or even if you didn't miss
out to have all those off the rep is
crazy so I just I guess okay okay
are you gonna go now and just download
all all the games just off of GP just so
you can have access to them after the
time yeah yeah I mean it's almost like
and just delete them off the hard drive
but you still have that yeah just had
the credit for it and that's that's the
thing though right when you go play this
is one thing the PlayStation does better
than Xbox in the in their store with
Xbox with PlayStation you go in like
their monthly games they have the option
to just add it to your library to
initiate the download then cancel the
download and then yeah and then it shows
it as claims yeah you can just be like
look claim it it's in your library you
don't have to even initiate the download
of that with this
I don't know how it works because it
doesn't give you that option so you go
in
and it will say download but there's no
option I tried it I said download yep
and then I I exited all the download and
then it didn't say anything about its
claimed it's there whatever now mind you
a lot of these games have been part of
regular PS plus throughout the years
right so I might have collected those
somewhere along the line but I it's not
the same so I I kind of wonder if you
just have to download the whole damn
thing which is weird that is weird but
yeah look I just I'm a little
disappointed by that because it's just
like you know
I guess I'm curious what the reasoning
like is it like we're going harder now
with PlayStation Plus and the tier
system and we not won't give you this
anymore and we trying to push you there
I just didn't understand it because I
felt it was a great service that they
offered initially so that was I'm just
confused about it I was definitely
surprised to see that but that's all I
got anything else on this one y'all
um
now we're good to go super chats super
chats okay so we got
let me see I uh Mr two opinionated two
dollars which I Platinum God of War
Ragnarok hashtag just one hashtag salute
yes salute to you salute salute I'm just
ended it is fine you ain't got a
platinum
you know I Platinum so what I silver did
I bronze
I thought y'all take away that Glory
I'm taking the glory
[Music]
just one's underperformed Kai when one
hashtag just one finally sells this is
what the streets want bro we gonna act
like Last of Us Last of Us ain't popping
Horizon's like stop it like just the
excuses Bros deal with the question at
head where they at though
Randy just wins that just let's deal
with that it's not big excuses yeah you
act like Sony has the like they're the
first people to make third person
actually yeah like like Tomb Raider
didn't exist before Saudi like like just
ones didn't exist before soldiers stop
it y'all making excuses bro stop it
critical role in D show on YouTube had a
Persona commercial for Xbox game pass
nice very good no salute we got
chaosante five dollars per attack I
canceled my pre-order and I'm all in on
VR because even today when you go to
pre-order it's available for you day one
I expect deals post launch yeah and
that's that that's telling as well where
you can go and just get it now
the day before you can order super chats
take that off huh subscriber mode is
turned on that's what's that about I
didn't do anything yeah check that out
see what's going on I don't even know
how to change that yeah well I don't
know where it's at it just changed the
subscribable Super Chat like they put a
cut off they said it's a cut off only
subscribers can do super chats what's
what's this
you can't have that happen again yeah
well then why you should not subscribe
though
why didn't you hit the Subscribe wait a
second
wait a second why are you here if you
ain't subscribed wait a second
hold on a second you just outed yourself
man subscribe just hit that button hit
that like hit this [__] subscribe man
get the notifications wait a second man
we like you don't talk
amen I can't I can't Super Chat because
I ain't subscribe hit the Subscribe
button oh man wait a second I don't know
wait a second
you you wait a second
let's see don't let me have to get out
there
what's Happening Here I told you once we
get to 15 000 y'all can get a
PlayStation VR that you want you know we
can get these millions up or you can get
an Xbox and you can get a PlayStation
actually turn it on and play it but um
don't you
subscribe no I'm looking uh you you
could still uh Super Chat oh okay I've
never seen that message pop up like
lobster
subscribers only more I think added this
so he tried to stop the super chats the
show for going long and he's like he's
let me go shut this down
he's like this show going on too long
I'm hungry if y'all not about this light
he said we're not talking to you no my
mind says the same thing King we have
people in here that are doing the live
girl thing yeah unless you subscribe
somebody in here and not sub though like
you not just not give you dope bars
don't you like them that you like me
wait wait why don't you like me
tell me why I'm not your favorite
the truth
to me this is what it should be all oh
no no no on the real we could stop
people from from having Boston here
saying crazy stuff like the live chat
stuff and they got they got a sub to say
anything
like the dating site subscribe
no it's a lot of money it's just subbing
to them the sub
buttons
are doing it and it's five why can't we
do it just let y'all know
why you don't like exactly
listening
to me
we ain't getting the 15 grand unless we
start pushing people
yo how the hell don't make no sense it's
free it's like saying okay please and
thank you they said that y'all got
topped exclusive
I don't even have a certain duration you
hit sub you get a chat
I couldn't put a date how many people
said we got everybody in here that's
subbed wait until you become a member we
didn't say hey jump on the patreon I
just say why you don't like me oh you
hitting that like button don't then
don't like me but like God
I you don't like me
don't listen to him I want you to like
see what would you say we're in a
recession something expensive but why
you ain't sub into why you don't like me
I got on a whole fur coat you better
like me
what I could be doing to you guys this
oh don't do no no don't do members only
put that back come on don't do them like
that what I'm saying is please please
God thank you like me thank you sir
thank you addict did something he got
gangster real quick
I was trying I was trying to figure out
how to fix that how to do it
who could have known I did
and we got ko3 black truth five dollar
Super Chat can't make remakes when
you're giving the game away for free
oh God now that was something that I was
thinking about
I mean you gotta if the Remake had to be
great to get make people but again the
Remake and we're talking about gears
here you're gonna you're just gonna put
the game in the game pass anyway so like
no he's talking about the I think it was
probably the PlayStation plus stuff oh
okay so you can't make a remake of a
game oh yeah pulling it off the service
put your chat on exclusively everybody
two positive attacks certainly needs to
get up off that VR passion project I
guess is Mark cerny's pass I don't think
this was Cerny bro I really think this
was Jim I don't think he don't know
anything about how VR really works
he said we need one of those stats
then we have B Lou
salute Lords keep killing it just wanted
your thoughts on Sony being ordered to
provide docs supporting their opposition
to Microsoft acquisition yes they got
subpoons somebody got to go to court and
bring their records so how they just had
a a fantastic fiscal year you're done
son you know you know what's funny
Microsoft is like you guys are snitching
on us we're gonna make you stitch on
something that actually is helping us
yeah they gotta show they face in court
just like Gunner took that plea deal but
he had to go sit in front of Young Thug
and tell Young Thug yeah why it sells a
game
ah that was his stuff so you they
pulling Sony in court now we now we
gonna have the joke now we're gonna have
Jim on Stan
[__] say well well Jim what was your um
sales records uh last week
let them know the millions you've been
there oh that's what they were here
yo that's when God
what's the battle pass coming for the
chat
to be fair with you or wrote it to Pax
is kind of a battle pass
I can't continue here we got Dave Ramos
two dollar super chats just a shout out
to say hi hashtag folks
thank you
then we have remedy live one pound and
79 Pence Super Chat great show guys
catch you next week thank you brother
appreciate you being here you say we got
loot crates for the chat
then we got Mr mdj two dollar stupid
chat King hit homie with the Nate Dog
hold up wait
you know what's funny too people clown
on me I just looked at our numbers we
went up 40
subscribe it worked it worked it worked
yes shaming works
that we have done the taco five dollars
in the chat Cog are any of those Sony
and hashtag just ones from last gen more
successful than tea of Thieves and above
average game as a service no hashtag
just one is not needed Wow
first of all did you see how many live
service games just got canceled yes you
letting them go in on you cause no no I
just like it because I like it
the emotionality when these games do
well and it bothers their soul what is
what is the issue with been indulging
around making this type of game like I
don't get it I don't get it I don't get
it I know what it is it's the
emotionality that because you're not a
fan of that platform it means you're
copying and we don't want to copy what
they're doing no I want to copy the hell
out of them hell yeah it's emotions I
want your emotions out I want you know
how they got the last of us I want the
best of us exactly exactly I just want
one of those numbers
I wanted this I wanted to look the same
sound the same and smell the same I
don't see listen we have Gears of War
right they have God of War you know you
don't listen we're not playing Let's us
do what they do you don't think Sony
wants to see your thieves too what you
know what I'm saying so we gotta stop
with it again get your feelings out of
it those games are successful Tony wants
to see these so much that they made like
10 of them to try to get something
thank you thank you Eric and if one of
them sticks and all I'm saying if one of
the third party hashtag just would stick
for Xbox they gonna be happy with the
reports so listen about the cap
gamer by choice five dollars to attack
what if Xbox is not doing third person
games because they do not want to
compete in that space would you play
against Jordan knowing you're gonna lose
yeah so don't complain at all don't get
better yeah
excuses listen you said play against
Jordan knowing you're gonna lose
when I was in Allen Iverson crossed over
Jordan and broke his ankles his angles
he ain't beat Jordan
overall yeah but that's iconic moment
showed that God can bleed yeah we could
do that that's what if God can bleep
if God can bleed you can kill it yeah
for sure
good to you and we got sir duck two
dollars to attack the Lord's trying to
make the club exclusive they're blamatic
for them I don't know I had nothing to
do with that they're doing it please put
up the battle pass there we go then we
got time let me hit that members chat so
maybe quick on that too his fingers then
we got Tom 909 two pound Super Chat I'm
loving you through that I'm loving you
through that fur coat King thank you sir
I was cold as hell so
I ain't gonna sit here and cap I was
cold as hell then we have masokista five
dollars in the chat I have a feeling Jim
Ryan is gonna Jimmy psvr too all the
classics people want back like so karma
gonna be psvr 2 exclusives that'll be
nice just make them PlayStation 5
exclusive not gonna sell but let them
happen
then we got Tom from Toonami hold on a
second I got jumped here for a moment
time between I mean five dollars to
attack we're about to start hearing
about a lot of them Sony games as a
service being canceled bet it could be
we see we'll see
we'll see then we I don't think so
Dragon heart yobi five dollar Super Chat
addict The Golden Child you are the
chosen one
it's Golden Child man I could kill you
guys
then we have one pint Johnny
Johnny just one fight he's done here for
the banter you guys are hilarious thanks
for the last fellas thank you brother
thank you appreciate it hold on a second
is that it yeah we're caught up all
right
but the recent impressive Sailors of God
of War Ragnarok which upcoming
PlayStation title do you think has the
best shot of beating Ragnarok numbers
the choices are a Marvel's Wolverine
B Marvel Spider-Man 2. see Final Fantasy
VII rebirth or D I don't care naughty
dog is entered to chat
[Music]
shout out to everybody's gonna go up on
the IOP Channel salute to the Realms
with everybody having fun today this was
a wild show anyway Lord attic where can
I find people find what you got going on
sir you can find me on Twitter at Lord
addict ILP first off I want to thank
everyone for coming through you guys
showed up in big ways today you know we
we have a lot of stuff that we have
planned obviously we kind of teased the
cliff thing you know we're going to try
our best to get him on I think you guys
are going to enjoy you know just overall
this year we got some other guests that
we're we're scheming man we're scheming
you know I ain't gonna lie to you guys I
try I try to try to brute face
Maximilian on here
that dude a little bit too too uh two up
on the on the totem pole I didn't know
this I looked he had 12 000 people
watching him on Twitter yesterday but
I'm gonna try man I'm gonna pull up on
some of these people in person with some
of these people in person next to you
yeah yeah we need you need the big black
dude the big white dude
that's kind of scary yes
they turn you into the whole Oreo
[Laughter]
so keep in mind we owe you guys a
community stream and a round table the
reason I did the sub thing is because I
think I'm going to try something
different when it comes to the roundable
table podcast I don't know how I'm gonna
do it yet but I'm going to look into it
um this Tuesday at uh you know Tuesday
Wednesday I'm going to be streaming um
the the Harry Potter game uh there's my
twitch so definitely go over there and
check that out I think you guys are
going to enjoy that like I said I'm
Gonna Be a Menace to Society Hogwarts
ain't gonna like me you know when I'm
done with that game they're gonna say yo
we wish we had uh what's that dude's
name
that I was in that game man they go they
they gonna go to him to come to me
that's what they gonna do so bad so bad
so where can I find people find you what
you got going on so let me get the Super
Chat first Donald tackle five dollars
all right here come adjust one Super
Chat feelings nothing against the
hashtag just one The Last of Us Part Two
was one of my faves ignoring the other
games it just underperformed to push his
attention and just like you're pushing
your agenda with all other live service
games that didn't underperform but
salute to you for acknowledging that
last of us at least we we're making
progress that's good there's
acknowledgment and I like that that's
right so we got Stitch five dollars to
protect a five dollar emo pack DRM and
weekly challenges just to chat is this a
mobile game that's right
we go sit there and act like I said I
put it on members only I didn't so stop
acting like that that's not what
happened all I said is I want you to
press one button to talk in that chat
and I turned it off okay I turned it off
but first quality
entertainment every week
we do it multiple times I want to know
all right I'm not your favorite
so that would be your food
I don't follow the follow helps immense
yeah it does look at algorithms no doubt
so yeah uh beyond that yeah you know me
I'm working hopefully by uh this time
next week I will be playing on my new uh
baby Beast
we'll see hopefully it arrives um but
yeah I'm excited for that excited to
play Hogwarts no doubt Lord King we can
find people finding what you got going
on Sir oh you can find me in this Fair
cover nice and warm
you can find me with people that like me
oh damn is it like this subscriber Chad
is going on man they look like y'all
y'all want this left on yo
I thought they liked me like I thought
it was ranking US like how you gonna be
here and don't just subscribe like yo
even the the the the sex Channel thing
is
this guy he hit the Subscribe long time
ago how you gonna let the sex bot beat
you come on man nah nah subscribe love
us
you can find me Tuesday at 5 PM with
Arnold with the Lord with attic I think
I'm supposed to watch uh you right
you pop up
you know my wife was like you you yeah
she was like oh look season two is up oh
we gotta get outside is that that
stalker that stalker the stalker one
yeah
it's a good it's a good show man they
have up to three seasons right now and
they're about to start the fourth so
addict right now is um watching chainsaw
man somebody put in there that they had
to do chainsaw man so
um I'm doing Attack on Titan but we're
gonna do the live reaction Attack on
Titan in the background so that's gonna
be really dope we're both gonna be there
I'm gonna be the one that knows it all
and I'm just gonna I'm gonna capitalize
on his reaction we'll see what he's
going to be is he's going to be uh damn
I can't even use that word uh I'm just
gonna be the young padawang I can't even
say that you know who he's gonna be
because it doesn't it
technically don't it looks bad Optics so
I'm not gonna say it um y'all figure it
out later anyway so attic is going to be
there with me uh kind of hand holding
and giving me insight and I'm gonna be
reacting to what I'm seeing on screen
because something crazy just happened in
Titanfall I mean a type wow
that's what I like no it's not gonna
happen continue um
something crazy just happened and I'm at
the cusp of finding out something huge
because it blew my mind when this thing
happened before and I was freaking out
and I called attic I'm freaking out on
the phone he said stop watching now yeah
I told him he can't watch any further
until we react to him right so we gotta
do just to clarify he's at the part
where the female Titan gets ripped apart
so people know what's about to happen
right so they had the female Titan all
uh all chained up and stuff and then she
did some Beastie that I did not see
coming this show just like addicts says
and it's it's it's slowly climbing to my
top of my anime chart thing that's
business yeah I was hating because in
the beginning I was falling asleep like
God got a
and now you're trying to keep yourself
awake to watch another episode I needed
to have this Focus that's what I had
today yeah and um I'm not gonna lie
Titanfall I mean yeah see there you go
yeah speaking into existence Brothers
let it come from your heart yeah let it
come from your heart it meant something
it's not gonna happen yeah Attack on
Titan
it has this weird thing
where they don't give you too much
because you're always like wondering oh
you think it's going this way just like
Alex said you think it's going down this
Corridor but then
it's a left turn or right turn so this
thing is is probably it's gearing up to
be one of the best whodunits that I've
been watching and it's dope so you can
catch me on r r with the Lord's talking
about this I'm gonna watch those uh
three episodes of you we're gonna
definitely talk about the next episode
of The Last of Us attic is talking about
chainsaw man and we're gonna probably
throw one more movie in today or
whatever for attic and how to watch
something on the side but definitely
please tune in and and that's the link
to our patreon if you want to go there
and see these reactions uh it's behind
the paywall I'm sorry guys so it is yeah
yeah you want to see me perform you got
to like me for real
that was wow
very only fan that was very only fans
and I'm right there you want to see me
perform oh wow
Tom I don't want to see you perform like
that
you want to see me before
no you can't be doing it see this what
happened with subscriber only come on
Focus
you on that song Today y'all
crazy he's crazy
look salute everybody to chat and all
that good stuff is absolutely hilarious
we got more stuff 290 episodes coming up
on 300 trying to do some fun things
something may or may not have something
may or may not happen but we'll see but
we honestly don't know we don't know we
don't know but look we're gonna try to
make it pop regardless good to see y'all
some of it any more Super chance I think
yeah we had a couple we got a couple oh
we got ko3 black truth five dollar Super
Chat 25 mil got award 2018 only 11 mil
wanted the DLC hashtag this one looking
scary they got 11.3 bumps my God stop it
black truth I love you stop it I like
you black shoes
Wolverine also got a war as a
multi-platinum yo
flat thing whatever I don't know I'm
looking at that last chat oh my God what
happened well here we go we got time 909
um
what are you gonna do eggplant
[Applause]
what is this what is this about about
Wolverine being multiplat yeah what is
this about I doubt that very much I
don't know when that happens that's when
it's on
are we good we are done
super chat if you want to see me
foreign
[Music]